Oh,
we live.
All right.
Hold on guys.
I got to do a commercial,
the Joe Rogan experience podcast.
First of all.
Hello.
Hi,
my friends.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by the fleshlight.
Um,
these guys are not just the sponsors.
We've actually hung out with them.
We are friends with them.
They're nice people,
and they make a,
a solid product from masturbation.
The number one sex toy from men in the world.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and enter in the code name Rogan under the fleshlight
link,
you get 15% off and a,
with that said,
here we go.
Buckle up.
Bitches.
Shit's about to get freaky.
The Joe Rogan experience.
Yes.
You know,
people complain about that drum thing in the beginning that don't,
don't smash the complaining man,
that fucks in my hearing.
Dude does it.
I don't like it.
It makes me,
blows my speakers up.
It's there to let you know you're alive.
Wake up and you know,
waiting to let you know it's uncomfortable.
Yeah.
It doesn't feel right.
It doesn't sound good.
It's sort of hook that would be better than then.
Then you just talking like,
hi,
I'm here.
Maybe I'll come on.
Maybe that's better.
No.
Is there a better term beat is there is no better.
No better.
There's no better.
Ladies and gentleman that drove.
He was tight man.
Brian Whittaker and Darryl writer in the house.
Ladies and gentlemen.
What's up guy?
Too?
Mad savages attacking the comedy scene in Los Angeles out there.
Fucking making shit happen.
You guys in the grinder out there whiten and scratching.
Yeah.
First of all,
thank you for having me on it.
They should be and on my friend Doug.
I appreciate it.
I'm glad you're both here and it's funny.
Well,
it's accidental that Brian's here.
Like Joe was like,
who the fuck is that?
I'm I no.
I'm like,
Oh darn.
I might've brought some crazy friend.
No,
always at blog.
We want to pull my friend to see your face,
man.
I saw the sunlight and it's like,
but the last time we had someone here,
Pito Hanson brought his wife and she just started talking while we're in the
middle of conversation and we had to give her a microphone.
I haven't met her man.
She's nice.
She's nice,
but it was,
but it was squirrelly.
Yeah.
He's like,
he's attached Bro.
There's dudes that are attached to their wives and some days you never see that
mother fucker without her.
It's like this is the unit.
They come as a unit.
They don't,
they don't come individually.
It is what it is,
man.
It's your turn to talk,
but that's like roughing Atlanta now.
Yes.
That's like Ralphie and Latin and then
they're like attached at the hip.
She,
yeah,
she's a sweetheart.
But you don't see Brian.
Is his microphone nylon or something?
Yeah,
it's fine.
It's just that he's so calm.
I just,
I,
yeah.
How's that?
Yeah,
but Darrell's Darryl's doesn't sound right.
It doesn't sound right to me either,
but yeah.
No,
I was thinking it now.
It does now does.
Okay.
Folks at home.
What the fuck at all this time over a year,
trying to get our technical fucking shit.
[inaudible] work with us.
I had technical envy when I went to Adam Carolla's place.
I went to Adelaide for his house to do the podcast down.
Motherfuckers got his shit wired.
I'm an amateur man.
He's got stacks of compressors.
I mean stacks of audio.
Compressor's not just one,
but we don't even have one.
If when it gets loud and hurts your ears,
sorry,
someone's schooling,
you'll fuck when he starts going off.
I have Brian has to dive on the microphone thing.
It's like a staff is what?
How many of you would you say that a lot of people working for him?
He's doing like
12 jobs right now.
You're not.
Adam does totally different set up.
First of all,
unimpressed people
after ghetto ghetto as fuck.
He's got people working like the cameras.
He's got like individual cameras on each individual person and then someone
manning a switch inside,
so there's a person who does that.
Then there's a person who looks up stuff on the web and pulls it up.
As you're talking about it.
So like I have to Google shit myself.
He's got to do to pull shit up on some giant big screen and then he's got a
sound effects board,
which is,
that was the one thing that I would cut.
You're like in the middle of the conversation that dude hits buttons and it
sounds like a jail cell close and another one sounds good.
Dork man.
He,
he uh,
he does his podcast club and it's like an hour and a half set up.
It's tight.
Like if people go to see it live,
it's fucking wild,
wild west.
Wild.
That mother fucker can go off on anything.
He went off on the public school system in la by the time he was done,
I was ready to vote for mayor.
I'll register.
You're the mayor now.
You're the mayor of La.
The last time that you voted?
I voted for Obama.
Okay.
Ahead.
I didn't,
I'm not happy about it now.
Now I just feel like I got duped.
I feel like a dumb ass.
I feel like it's all the same.
I just feel like I,
I went against my own thinking on all this stuff I've always said I'll take,
so like pro wrestling,
you know,
it might make you feel like you're,
you're doing you and you're rooting on pro wrestling.
You might feel like you're participating but I don't really think it counts.
I think you got to kind of give them a break and you know like for at yard at
never that don't know me.
Joe knows me.
Race is not an issue with me.
Like I'm,
I'm a Nascar Fan.
I'm a country music fan so it ain't one of those things.
But I think in this particular case it's,
he's the first black president and he doesn't want to overstep his bounds.
That's what I'm hoping that it is.
Well that's silly.
He fucking treading really lightly because he's like,
he's like really treading really lightly.
Cause what he should've said when he first got in and people started bitching,
it's calm the fuck down.
I'm cleaning up some of Nigga Shit.
I give me some time.
He hasn't even done that man.
He hasn't even fucking,
he hasn't really,
he hasn't really stepped on nothing,
man.
He's been walking around real light like he ain't
fucking Libya.
I mean like he's got this whole new,
well now I'm offended.
I'm offended that we're even talking about this.
Like we're even pretending we have a fucking clue.
Oh,
I can't vote.
So it's mad speculation.
I don't really care cause I can't vote.
So either way it don't matter to me man.
Darrell done some bad things and
I know that's coming.
I wonder why I'm asking Joey Diaz is that,
let's talk about what should we know about the Joey does is act.
It was an,
I can't vote mother.
All right.
I got some money.
Get fucked up,
man.
I don't,
no.
Whether Obama's real or not,
I don't know.
I don't know what it is.
But all this Wall Street shit watching inside job and reading all of them.
You Know Matt Taibbi is,
he's a writer for rolling stone.
He really know.
He's bright,
some independent stuff too,
but he's,
he breaks,
he's brilliant articles for rolling stone where he sort of like details the
depths of the corruption that's involved in the financial institution.
And it's like,
wait a minute.
First of all,
if this is true,
how the fuck is this the only guy talking about this man,
how is this the only guy screaming in the streets?
How was Matt,
Matt Taibbi the only bad motherfucker who's writing these articles?
It's exposing everything.
I mean there's,
there's the guys who made that inside job movie.
There's Matt Taibbi and then where the fuck are the politicians were all of
these guys,
why they getting paid?
Like it's,
it's money,
it's money.
It's about money.
For example,
of corruption we've ever seen.
Sure.
About money.
And the whole funny part is just like you would tell somebody to put a weed
dealer in jail,
the first Wall Street dude that has to do hard time.
It's over with.
They,
they will,
they will stop doing this shit.
So crazy.
No,
they want to start killing people.
That's what they'll start doing and start killing people that put people in
jail.
Cops will come up missing,
dude,
these are what you're talking about.
Level of dollars here you're talking about money that's beyond our
comprehension.
You're,
you're getting into like where guys are getting fired because their bank failed
and they're getting hundreds of millions of dollars in bonuses.
What that does it,
it's just,
it doesn't make sense.
Now see,
y'all are awesome deeper thinking than I am.
When is it that people are going to just grabbed the pitch forks and start
chopping these dudes is
no,
as long as they're comfortable man,
as long as there's enough comfort where people can sleep and they can watch
cable and they can get fucking Wendy's,
you know,
and get the double cheeseburger and as long as that it's all there for them.
People aren't going to freak out.
When shit gets bad is when people don't have food.
When people don't have gas,
when people then then riots in the streets happened.
As long as they can keep the infrastructure up and keep supermarkets stuffed and
keep a reasonable amount of jobs available,
they can just keep fucking us
being the fucking increase lately and uh,
and these asshole bumps or drive up with a car like asking you for spare change
at the fucking gas station.
Like got a guy pull up in a car accident with her chin.
No,
they fucking,
they want money from you to make their cargo further there.
They're begging you at the gas station now from a car on a road trip,
road trip.
Especially at imagine it happens real bad in la.
No,
no.
He's saying what he's saying is that's a sad story out of mine.
Oh yeah.
Well
yeah,
I'm stranded.
Blah Blah Blah.
[inaudible] from home.
Go the fuck back.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm homeless.
Put on,
I'm talking about just guys who want money to make their cargo further.
That's it.
They just pull up,
they pull into a gas station and they stay there and they take up a pump and
they just want your fucking money.
They're just asking any,
I've never seen this once.
Oh No,
maybe I live in the right.
So you guys are getting an asked at the gas station.
Oh,
all the time.
This is the way I know more lately.
Fuck.
Do you live?
I live off of an album around,
yeah,
the Brown Franklin like by the,
by the Capitol records building.
Okay,
so you're,
you're in the hood.
You're,
I mean in Hollywood.
I didn't mean the hood.
You know,
you're writing the hardest things.
Trainee,
Boulevard,
Trendy,
whatever.
You know what man,
you're,
that's one of the things in white guys.
Brown
that's never happened
for money.
Not like that dog.
Like they,
they might hit me up for like change the fucking,
get something to drink,
but just drive your car up to the gas station.
They asked about somebody.
Oh.
And they take up the damn pump and they stay there until they get something.
Somebody would have been slapped me up for money at Disneyland when I was
carrying my kid in Disneyland.
Comes,
comes up to me and he's in Disneyland too.
Yeah,
he's in Disneyland to tells me some story about his parents.
I could do it.
Get the fuck Outta here.
Fuck do some young kid.
He's like 19 and 20 years old and he came up to me and just with this fucking
stupid story about his parents and he needs to get them somewhere and then
there's short did he knows I have no idea what he knew.
I didn't want to hear it.
I was like,
this is retarded.
You know you need to get a fucking job or shut the fuck up.
It's one or the other.
Either you're,
you're ripping people off because you're faking all this story or you need to
get your shit together and that's part of life.
You don't always have your shit together from the get go.
And when you're short on money,
sometimes you have to have peanut butter sandwiches or roll pennies,
assholes.
If the gas stations that you guys apparently never had to deal with,
I don't know,
in case anybody else has theirs.
Listen,
it's like if you can't afford a fucking car,
you know,
just get a bigger car called a fucking bus.
People were out there on the ground,
work for my car too.
What are the things that I think that I go through and I've been blessed in that
type of concept is just what you're,
you're saying?
And that's personal responsibility.
Like it's no secret I fucked up earlier but
I shot a crackhead head.
What's the story?
What happened?
Okay.
You want to get a job?
You want to hit a real story?
I want to both give me the joke first joke.
It did not ruin it.
Well anyway,
tell me the real story and then tell me the jug.
It won't be as good.
Right.
You know what the joke is?
The real story.
What happened was I was selling dope back in DC and uh,
this guy,
I had fronted him some front of them,
some dope actually it was crack and it was,
it was a crack head.
And like he was across the street from me and my boys and we were drunk on his
patio,
his shit,
and he was across the street and I was like getting my money motherfucker
drunk and leeway like high high and this one and this jackass is going to say
fuck you ain't paying you shit.
I think he owed me like $10 so all of my boys was,
we were like,
oh,
she's just going to let that crack here and talk to you like yeah,
and I'm drunk with a fucking gun.
So I shot across the street to scare this motherfucker,
but I hit him dope.
Yet the rest is history.
Wow.
How old were you then?
I was,
let's see,
I was 25 when that happened.
God Damn.
Did you realize after you pull the trigger where you like,
what the fuck am I doing?
Okay.
I didn't kill him.
I just shot his ass.
I still didn't think like,
what the fuck am I doing?
I just shot a guy.
It didn't know I was too drunk.
How drunk now when you,
how long were you selling crack for?
How many years?
Crack like year and a half.
But I was selling drugs,
like all types of drugs,
like just exclusively cracked,
like a year and a half.
I don't know man.
Like did you like listen to too many ice tea song?
No,
it had,
it had nothing to do with fucking rap music and nothing.
It was just like,
this is the thing that pisses me off.
And uh,
uh,
the,
the culture that you come from,
it's no,
well not me.
I mean not you but me.
The culture tries to dictate that you can't do nothing but certain things and be
successful.
Now I'm not a dumb motherfucker as y'all know,
cause you,
cause you've heard my county and stuff like that,
but that's a pretty bold of you.
But it is like,
you know what,
when you're a certain age,
just talk about shooting a crack head and it didn't really bother you that much
and then you're like,
I'm obviously very intelligent.
You guys know this.
Fucking you gotta look at yourself piece mark.
Cause I only did two years for that shit.
So Ryan and I are the only people that are high right now.
We'll just want to let you know folks at home.
Go on.
There's two different frequencies going on here.
Yeah,
it's Sarah.
I got Darrel high once and I was half of four fucking days.
Like I'm using smoking dirt weed and Joe got the good shit.
Him and Ralph.
He had that good shit.
We put them on Pluto.
I was,
I think I was seeing shit like I was talking to people that was dead and having
a conversation with them.
Just chilling dog.
Oh,
that's some superman shit that he smokes,
man.
I don't,
I'm not used to that shit dog.
I can't fuck with that.
It's the real weed,
bro.
That's the real we'd done.
Other stuff is fake.
That other stuff was just to get you to find the real weed.
It's good.
The other stuff is like,
wow,
this feels kind of good.
Well,
I'm Kinda hungry,
Paul.
Things are so funny.
I'm giggling.
He,
I was like,
this is not a kind of weed.
This weeds called train wreck.
No,
it was 40 I wasn't laughing at Shit.
Everything was cool.
Everything was serious because I was having conversations.
That was fucking,
you're having conversation with people who weren't there
while watching Nascar.
I watched NASCAR sober.
Don't try that shit.
He don't fuck around.
Nascar is a SYRAH NASCAR's.
Is that a NASCAR cap you're wearing right now?
What is it better not ask that question.
It's like number,
I feel
bad.
I don't know shit about any sports.
Dale Earnhardt.
Okay.
I heard he's dead.
Yes.
That guy's done.
He his son still racist.
You don't a lot of money in Nascar.
I just thought it was like,
sorry,
it's a lot of money in that shit.
You really didn't know that this was the alert for real.
How the fuck am I supposed to know that a number is some particular man's
number?
How would I know that as a very good question cause you were,
cause you,
you have seen that and have numbers on there.
No,
I don't.
Literally,
I don't even know the rules to basketball.
I don't know.
When someone gets mad at someone I'm like what did someone do?
I'm like,
wait a minute,
you're mad that he touched you.
You fucking pussy
whack ass sport is this.
We follow,
follow fighting mostly.
I mean like every other sport and at least I don't know about you,
but I mean like to me it's like every of the sport it's just kind of like a
delusion of,
you know,
like,
I don't know,
it's just like other sports.
It's watered down fighting and like you've talked to a fight and again I'm
interested,
do you like your face,
know how much you really trucking,
follow fight and like just,
yeah,
they pretty much know.
The thing about sports is that's what sports don't have.
Wood fighting doesn't have the sports do have like team sports is the,
the,
the joy of seeing all these people work together.
There's something beautiful about a basketball game or one dude makes a call on
the other dude fakes of pass run and passes it off and the other dude hits the
three and everything falls in line.
Like they practiced it and you're like,
look at that man,
look at that.
And everybody gets crazy and now high five each other.
You don't get that in fighting.
It doesn't exist.
So there's,
there's something about teamwork.
There's something beautiful about watching a soccer team pull off some crazy
past that they've rehearsed,
you know,
many times and the guy shoots the goal and there's something about that when
everybody gets together and hugs and cheers.
You don't quite ever get that in,
in fighting and fighting.
It's very much me.
It's individually
petition of um,
like I think even in comedy,
certain certain Comedians that competitive nature drives him
more than others.
A lot of people,
Eliza slash in German,
like she was talking about how it's heard number one thing that she's so
competitive then.
My God,
I have no problem with like God.
I think it makes for great comedy because you can be friends offstage,
but Doug,
when it's you and that microphone is,
that gets your juices going like
so.
You get real competitive too.
You can put it on not other friends and not competitive
in a negative way.
Like I don't dog other people's comedy cause I'm not the comedy police.
But what I do do is if you just killed and I'm not dying dog,
that ain't happening because it's that competition.
Like,
I'm not going to be the one that brings the show down.
You know what I mean?
It's funny.
Yeah.
I think I used to think about it like that.
I used to feel like that.
He used to feel like,
well,
I don't want everyone Obama to go up there and kick ass,
but now I don't think about it like that at all.
Now I only,
I only always think about like,
what's the best thing to think about?
The best thing to think about regardless of the circumstance is the act is,
what am I going to say?
What a w where's my head at?
What am I talking about?
That's the best thing to think about it.
As soon as you start thinking about peripheral shit,
like they're like he killed and what have they liked him more than me?
I want to make sure they don't
surly the competition that I'm thinking of,
but probably because of the fact that this,
you know,
I'm just getting to the point where I'm starting to,
even people started even thinking about me headlining.
Once you know that you,
you are the show,
it doesn't matter no more.
You know what I'm saying?
Like and just like you,
you,
you said,
I'm still scrapping out here.
You know what I'm saying?
As far as getting to to the point where I'm headlining.
So I got to kind of think that a little bit.
But once I know that I'm the show,
it doesn't matter whether the opener closer monkey out of his ass.
It really doesn't matter how long you been doing comedy.
Now it'll be nine years this year.
Nine years.
What about you Brian?
I don't really count.
Three.
Three years.
Yeah,
three years.
I mean that was just pretty much,
that was a,
yeah,
it was march.
March.
Oh wait,
sort of working at the NPR.
I was a,
I was a bouncer.
I came into this total fucking accident.
I was,
I was fucking,
I was a bouncer like right off skid row in downtown La,
like for two years.
Like in those little,
those bars they got out there to move the hipsters in and make it safe and
everything and you know,
just make the area,
I'm not familiar with that.
What do they to use this?
All right,
well basically they've been slowly,
slowly,
slowly pushing skid row in downtown la a little bit for their light just towards
the fucking river
for,
if you've never seen this by the way I,
we filmed fear factor down there.
We used to do downtown La shit all the time and I used to drive up skid row.
It is a fear
crazy for the folks that don't know.
There's areas of downtown La that are like a fucking George Romero Zombie world
that I see.
Especially at night.
I'm talking block after block of just crazed out homeless people who are
sleeping right there on the ground with shopping carts and you know,
one shoe on and tattered and everyone's crackdown on illegal.
After a while I'll go ahead.
Well they made it illegal after a while for them to put the tents up during the
day,
but they were always up at night her yet illegal.
You have to take your tent down.
There's another fucking thunder dome.
It's a whole goddamn thunder dome of just homeless or shooting politicians.
We made along.
You've got to take those tents down during the day.
I'm in subway and
I was just working out there as a bouncer for awhile and it got depressing after
a fucking bit.
So I was looking for a positive environment to go to,
to offer my services.
So I went to,
it was actually a comic,
Steve Simone,
he told me,
hey,
go try it.
The comedy club,
you know,
you'll be a security guy there.
So at the Improv Improv,
um,
and uh,
and then you started going on stage.
Yeah.
I mean cause that will really,
cause I,
yeah,
I just got a little bit pissed because I was stuck in the showroom Washington at
first I was so stoked because I was working around you.
All of this does laughter and everything like that.
And then I go into the showroom and I had to be making sure that everybody was
behaving during a show.
And so many of these comics just so just such a much a heartless hokey crap.
And you can tell they're just looking to,
they're not up there for the audience.
They're not out there to make people laugh it up there to get their fucking
little,
you know,
sit tree are going and all that.
And I got pissed and it was anger that drove me towards this stage.
So you went up
because of bad comedy.
Yeah.
That's interesting.
Made me and that I had to met me down.
You're hilarious and you've calmed the fuck down.
Do you know how wired you are?
Fucking weird.
Most people want to fucking fucking wipe my fucking money.
Fuck you man.
You can have my fucking money.
You know I sold these fucking comics neural heartless and Darryl knows I've
calmed down.
Darryl knows you've calmed down.
And Darryl also knows that.
Everybody knows he's smart.
This is a strange group,
you guys,
a little duo act.
We need to get a new fairly brothers script or on Youtube fucks
do some comedy shows like three times a year down there.
It's a big ass homeless shelter down there and I,
and I'll do comedy shows there like three times a year.
Really?
I will tell you,
man,
it's fucking,
it's a zoo man.
It is a zoo.
It's a human zoo.
Doing comedy in there is fun as shit.
Yeah.
Because really
no.
What else?
People who have made giant mistakes almost every step of the way.
It's been a mistake.
Well,
yeah,
that's,
that's a lot of human beings,
man has a point where they don't consider themselves human anymore.
They don't,
they're not at the end of the day to show him away for a living for a long time.
Just like shit being human is just like a,
some program that you run over the animal system that,
that runs the body and now being human,
it's just soup that's so fucking fragile.
So when do you think that the huge,
the humanity leads
soon as shit gets ugly on,
as soon as the power goes out,
as soon as there's no food,
as soon as your baby's crying,
as soon as this guy's got it,
you don't.
And as soon as soon as shit gets ugly,
and I look at New Orleans,
man,
no one ones.
We saw how ugly that caught.
There was some so many murders in New Orleans during the,
after Katrina.
They didn't even,
they can't even get it.
I don't even know what to do.
Niggas was murdering people in,
in New Orleans when the lights was on,
but it got worse.
It got way,
way,
way worse.
Got Worse with the cops to the cops went all Zombie vigilantism there were cops
were driving around in pickup trucks,
picking people off of guns.
There's a lot of crazy shit went down in New Orleans,
man.
A lot of people were killed.
No.
You know,
and that's just,
look,
yeah,
New Orleans is bad as it is,
but so's La man.
Look what happened when Rodney King with the Rodney King Verdict.
You know,
people forget about how crazy it got down here.
The place I'm in the country,
they have different rights in different cities and all that.
Hold on.
You guys can't talk at the same time.
I'm not going to run my hands.
Be Smart.
The whole theory.
Oh thank you.
This is the whole theory with that though.
That shit went crazy until it got to about Beverly and then that's when they
were like,
y'all niggas gotta go back to where y'all came from.
Y'All can,
y'all can burn that.
True.
Y'All can burn down Inglewood and you can burn down Compton.
But once it got to like Beverly ish,
that's when the national guard was like,
y'all ain't coming up here.
Is that what happened during the La Riots?
I was living here.
I was living in Palos Verdes is at a time I was 13 years old.
And I can say that just paddles verdict pieces out by a,
it's basically like South Bay area.
It's the where.
Um,
so where is it in relationship to a of ghetto?
I mean like basically it's,
yeah,
technically it's technically it's about 10 minutes away from 10 minutes away.
So your,
your clothes so you gotta be nervous.
I mean like really this is a freeway so it's not like they're gonna March down
the freeway straight.
Exactly.
This scary people.
It's ugly.
I think it could be kind of like a,
a physical barrier.
This more than just cops.
When it comes to these,
I mean la is kind of like this,
it's like this big circle and on the inside of the circle is like this is the
pit of Shit and all that.
And on the outside like you're kind of safe like the beach and then the hills
and everything like that.
And it's like this physical barrier
for level one to level two and three situations.
Everything's off limits.
There's chaos in the streets.
The cops have been in their positions,
but we were talking about this,
Robert,
is this stop where like when you come to a hill like this,
you start because you're thinking,
if I get caught up here,
I'm fucking,
I'm not getting out of it.
But listen to what I'm saying.
This is only level one stuff you're talking about.
No chaos.
You talking about no loss of civility you're talking about it's basically
society is running and it's just a few fuck ups that are going crazy.
Well when the shit hits the fan,
if the shit ever hits the fan,
probably not going to be like that.
It's not going to be lecture.
There's not going to be civility.
No,
of
course not.
I mean cause like just being in jail like
it's a whole nother world and it's like a,
I think a lot of times that I'm still kind of institutionalized with like just
little shit.
Like I can't sleep in my house without a door or like a window open like patio
door.
Why?
I don't know.
It's just something that,
you know,
somebody can sneak in your house in the middle of the night if they want it to
tell people you don't want people to come in and kiss you.
Come on,
guess what you're asking.
Any Lehman would come on in,
you can leave.
I mean come in,
but you ain't leaving.
You're scared of kisses.
Oh fuck that.
Well,
yours is this a freedom thing?
Yeah.
It's like,
it's like,
it's like being able to know even subconsciously then I'm not trapped.
Yeah.
Wow.
How many years were you in jail for?
Two to dam and it's like,
um,
even with what you were saying,
like I hate when people use the term subtle to anything.
It's like,
it's just terminology nowadays.
It's just pissing me off because it's like dark.
I'm a firm believer that it ain't no such thing as racism.
No more.
Are you talking about I'm raising
those Nascar motherfuckers.
Got You.
Brainwashed.
It's true.
Racism,
sexism and racism and black people.
Heat light,
Brown people.
It's not that.
It's like that is some shit that people make up so that they can make money off
of that shit.
Oh my God.
Jesse Jackson has a,
W Jesse Jackson has a w two man.
No,
I'm,
I'm not trying to need,
we need to pause this thing that you both bought.
You need to get high
because,
listen,
Joe,
listen to this though.
Listen to my theory.
My theory is this.
When you give yourself an excuse to fail,
then you have that excuse.
Whereas there was a,
there was a time that my race could stop me from accomplishing certain things.
Those days are over with now,
so as far as the racism as we think it is,
I don't think it's that anymore.
My race can't stop me from doing anything that I wanted to.
Dude's certainly less intense,
but it doesn't.
Just because it can't stop you from accomplishing your goals doesn't mean it's
not there.
No matter what you do,
it is human nature.
It is a genetic imperative that we judge.
We look at genetics,
we look at the shape of a woman's body.
Your,
your body tells you this is sexually attractive because this is a woman's going
to have good babies.
It's,
it's the,
our entire society is set up.
You look at people that are bigger than you.
You become intimidated.
It's natural.
That person can dominate you physically.
All this shit is in place.
You look at people that aren't you,
they're black and I'm white.
Maybe they'll side with themselves and maybe they're on their own team and I
should be afraid of them because this is a different team.
It's almost completely natural now as an intelligent person,
you're supposed to be able to recognize this is just a human being that was born
Chinese and this is a human being that was born African and this,
and then it's all just some crazy lottery.
We were all in this together and you should judge people in their actions.
That is,
that's,
that's the intelligent evolved approach,
but how many fucking people are intelligent and evolved?
It is natural that racism is going to exist.
It's going exist just like being stupid.
It's,
it is.
It is when it's a human instinct.
Well,
well I think right now if I want it to,
you could be,
if I want it to,
if I'm not going to exist in this room,
that it could exist,
but to me it's still insanity.
Well,
you're saying,
you're saying two totally different things and on one hand I totally agree with
you that you can accomplish anything you want to do on an oftentimes you put
limitations on yourself saying,
you know,
hey,
as a black man,
I'm never going to pass this.
Hey,
as a guy who was born up here,
I'm never going to be on television.
I'm never going to do that.
You can impose those limitations on you right there.
Those are self fulfilling prophecies,
man.
You can really decide your life is going to be a shitty life.
You're absolutely correct about that.
No one can stop you from doing what you want to do,
but they will try.
Don't think they will say things.
Don't think racism is there.
No,
it's not fair.
But you can't say racism isn't real it.
Fuck yeah,
it's real.
But it doesn't mean that it has to stop you and it doesn't mean we have to
tolerate it,
but it means it slowly.
We're moving away from the animal,
but how long have we been a human?
I mean when you go back at what point in time is it stopped being a human,
is it Australia pithy kiss and went,
what the fuck?
Which,
which,
which monkey is it where you say that's not a human anymore.
So everything from that is trying to get away from being an animal.
The animal is still here though.
It takes some time to get all that shit out of your system.
Well,
you also have to,
you also have to be,
I think,
forward thinking in type of concept because you know what,
for instance,
I'll give you a great example of this.
You know what I'm saying?
Um,
just the fact,
and this is gonna sound weird,
just the fact that I'm on this podcast,
for instance,
it's,
it's plenty of of comics that I respect and I love,
but they would not let me into their home.
So what does that,
you know what I'm saying?
Is that racism or is that just
you say that though.
Every time we've hung out you're like,
man,
I'm so happy hanging out with me and look at the fuck you talking about.
We're all hanging out together.
But you said that to me when I've gotten you on stage before you said you know
this guy,
but I don't stress we get,
we all go on stage.
But I don't keep putting that shit on yourself.
No,
but you don't understand the stages that I normally get up do though.
Cause I seen you at the Improv and you get at the Improv Bro.
It ain't,
it's not like you only get these shitty places,
but
saying that to say this is not a matter of what race I am as far as that's
concerned.
It's just the comfort level.
You know what I'm saying?
And where were you were saying that people see stuff a certain way?
I think that I programmed myself to put race
CISM out of the picture and just handle myself a certain way.
I can't,
I don't understand that with your mind.
Right.
Understanding that you are doing that.
So,
so,
so maybe me making that blanket statement was a little bit too much,
but in my mind,
I can't see racism as an option for me to blame something or something exterior
for me not doing what I got you.
We can have an awesome TV show where take you and put you in a fucking bow tie
and burn your around white neighborhoods in the south and you will see some
fucking racism like you wouldn't believe.
Add to what you're saying.
I mean,
I've like been to the south man.
I know you have it.
I love the south because my hope is what I'm saying.
You by yourself with a clipboard going through white neighborhoods.
Smile there.
Now see now
every time someone calls you a nigger need more paper
paper.
Well you need a fucking phone book.
That's what
we're not,
I wouldn't say racism either.
I think that's always a bold statement.
He's Megan.
But I mean like honestly,
like we're at a point now where it's like,
all right,
when,
when when people,
wingers for instance,
okay wiggers people say
they wish they were black,
they were sealed bad.
Saying wigger
I feel when I say we're going to somebody,
I feel like I kinda sorta said,
nigger,
mother fucking trigger fingers.
Don't want to be black.
You got to remember,
I'm trying to tell him and I'm like,
we're just trying to be black people.
Like this is like an old taking this way too seriously.
This is what the fuck are you laughing with us?
He's got his wigger point that he wants to get through your point.
More powerful.
And I say fucking wigger too.
All right.
They don't want to be black.
They're winners.
All right.
They're not,
we're not talking about they want to be when African Americans,
they want to be there.
Wiggers you know,
I mean like,
they're not looking to take Obama's place one day
trying to be these thug ass retards,
like the lowest of what the black race could possibly have to offer.
And I mean like basically this is just something that is,
again,
generalize in the old school thought.
Whereas nowadays
you can say any blocking and talking about some nonsense.
Tro In jazz,
right.
Fucking make his point so I can get hired firing up.
You're talking nonsense.
So I know it's like,
go ahead cause I'm getting,
listen,
it's very,
it's important to get called on nonsense talk cause you can go your whole life
talking nonsense and get away with
fed shit.
I'm starting to have heart palpitations right now about the show from what?
From being so high right now.
Coffee,
coffee.
But I could always get hired.
Joe,
I had the most crazy thing happened to me last night.
I found out about a whole new sex fetish that I had no idea existed.
And it's the most disturbing fucking thing in the rug.
It's for kids when you're a kid and your mom yells at you and you liked it,
you know like you know when your mom used to yell at you,
you hated it.
But there's people out there that when you're,
their mom yelled at them,
they loved it.
And so when they grew up,
they like these things called gigantic women.
And so,
you know like the old saifai videos of like,
you know,
the attack of the art crumb type women or giant,
the attack of the 50 foot women and stuff like that.
So there's now fetish websites where it's like little GI Joe characters and like
naked girls.
And it's fucking so creepy though.
The lifestyle that,
that there is a,
there's also this,
there's the fetishes women with dolls,
women with small dolls that they kind of 10 that it's a person.
Yeah.
And like they're bad.
They're like,
they like command them to do things.
They lock them up in cages when they have full on movies.
Wait a minute,
the women command the dolls to do things or they're,
they're,
they're yelling at the dolls,
like,
you know,
kind of like as a mom,
like I was talking to one of the girls that was in one of these movies and
they're like,
yeah,
it's really weird because like,
you're yelling at these dolls and then like one would knock over and then you'd
have to kind of set it back up while you're in scene and stuff like that.
So I went to this website,
and this is a beautiful website.
The,
at first I was shocked,
but now I think I love this shit.
And I think it's the coolest shit ever.
It's called giantess.net g,
I,
N T,
e s energy I a n t,
I a n t e s s.net and they have forums,
they have chat rooms and they have everything like that.
But the crazy thing is that they sell clips like,
like girls,
girls small.
Look at this shit.
Look at this
calls with little penises that they're like sucking on the doors and then
there's like parts where like they're putting dolls in ohm.
I think they'll feel yelling at the dogs when they put them in each other.
Yeah.
Why is it dolls?
I don't get it.
It's because it's the little man big Gi doll.
Yeah.
Maybe pretend that that's damn or something people.
People sit there.
It's a little green Dominic dolls and even look,
humans are stupid looking thing.
It's got a big flat bottom where it has to stand up.
You know,
like it's surfing.
That always bugged me out about those dolls.
Like you pee,
you can't even make a doll.
Army men,
right.
Candidate can't even make one that stands on its own.
You have to have a surfboard under it everywhere.
It can't even pretend.
My favorite shits,
the Emily Parker ones.
If you look at search that website for the Emily Parker,
it's also on size fetish zone.com and you'll just become addicted to this shit.
Well,
I'm looking at the forums right now,
man.
Look at this.
I'm afraid scientists and small men.
Oh my God,
this forum is stuffed.
Yeah.
And it's so strange.
It's all these girls and they're sucking these dicks of these little tiny men
have like little Dixie they put on them.
This is so strange is awesome.
It's super popular.
And it's weird like when you see the Scifi movies with the TAC,
the 50 foot woman,
most guys just go,
wow,
that's kinda cool.
A big woman.
But there's people addicted to that shit.
Like that's what gets him off.
Wow.
So I spent
a lot of people would a lot of time on their fucking,
she's at a time thing,
man.
Or it's a
developing a human being from child to adult is very,
very complicated and all sorts of things are set up in place,
you know,
to make sure that you become a successful person or to encourage you.
And when those things get hijacked and weird shit happens,
like abuse,
you know,
weird little little fucking fetish is developing the mind.
This check this that says this,
this is a trailer.
If you go on youtube and type in giant his trailer 2009 this is kind of giving
you a sample where it shows a really,
oh my God woman and little people love and it's,
it's,
and she's standing around in the middle of the street.
Oh my God,
you crushed it
and look at this.
It's just giant women and small men.
Well there's small women in their underwear.
Women are stomping on them and there's swallowing them and stuffing them in
their pussies.
And this only came from their mom's yelling at him.
That's what supposedly like the people that are into this thing.
It's has a mom in small,
these ones are,
yeah,
that's a big bitch.
Just goes to show.
It's how you're built,
man.
You can put any kid through anybody.
I guess it's just how you're built.
That is insane.
That's amazing.
That's insane.
And I'm addicted to it now and now have that fetish and it's not for a boner.
Totally.
See where that's going.
I could totally see where that's going.
That's trench.
Yeah.
I,
I've always thought about that because you know,
like the Indian in the cupboard,
I was always thinking like,
wow,
you know,
this is a book for kids about a naked half dressed man that it's put in.
He kept them in his pocket and his name is like big bear or something like that.
And there was something weird and sexual about that yet.
Naked Indian guy and your kid,
if your kid,
if your kid came up to you,
they get Indian man in your pocket,
you'd be fucking pissed.
Was he a naked one or he one of those Indians
would all the feathers and shit.
Yeah.
Well,
no,
he had,
I think he just had like that little loin cloth on little loin cloth with a
little feather fall hanging out on one side.
Weird little naked man hiding in your fucking plates.
And the kid was like,
never tell your parents about our secret con.
That's like it's a fucking Indian in the cupboard,
man.
They don't make then they make the sex stories like that.
That was there a movie.
But in these,
who was in that movie?
Somebody romantic
fuck a little girl down.
Who was in it?
The guy from the,
Oh my God.
What's the movie with,
no,
the guy from the,
from the movie where they keep going to weddings and fucking bitches.
Oh,
wedding crashers.
Yeah.
The wedding crashers.
The one guy from the wedding crashers went in it cause he,
cause he played a cowboy from 1995 and then they played a cowboy in that house.
Scardino Lightfoot and Lindsay crouse are listed as the actors.
Oh no,
he was in,
no,
he was in the Smithsonian movie now
telling you we had to have a new rule no more.
So people when they'd come over here and they don't smoke weed,
okay,
look,
here's,
here's what the deal was.
Let's be,
let's be perfectly,
but I am a drinker.
So you were about to say perfectly blunt,
but you don't even say that word.
Now don't even say I am a,
I am a drinker,
but I wasn't going to come to Joe's house.
Fucked up.
Listen,
you bitches need to get on some comedy steroids.
That's what's going on.
I need to get on this.
We'd stop playing around playing games.
You're playing games in the future.
You're risking,
you're risking a future talking nonsense.
Ooh,
I'm not talking about you can save you from this can save you from an about
pedophilia,
shit and all that.
I'm still tripping out who?
Who the fuck pedophilia is important.
That is whatever that is.
We need to find out about that.
We need to invest in the fucking ass time for that Shit,
man.
I know it's not a time thing,
It's like that's what they liked best.
If they had all the time in the world,
they would do that.
If they had an hour a day not to do that.
How do you find out that you like that shit?
That's a good question.
No,
it's no,
it's more than your mom yells at you,
got your mom spanked you and then she felt bad about it so she jerked you off.
You know what I'm saying?
It's like something like that has to happen early on that man.
That's some shit where as though you have to discover that you like that shit
man.
You have to discover that.
And then the crazy thing about the internet is if you like something you'll just
gotta be a website out there where there's a gang of other people that love it
too.
You know it's not like the old days scary zoo.
Oh my God.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
Cause I mean they were talking about how like they thought they were alone and
then the internet came out and then there are other people who fuck horses too
and it's okay.
I can be part of a club now.
I mean it just,
it was one of the weirdest documentaries ever.
It's weird how they did it too.
Cause it was like a reenactment.
They didn't really have footage so they had a,
but they were just cutting away real quick.
The editing with a fucking note.
They had like the actual video of the dude getting fucked to death by the horse
and then like the hardy were fucking disturbing.
I mean sure you can imagine that much but I mean I admitted I got rock hard
though.
Did you get hard?
What part?
What part got your hard during the fucking other horse.
All right,
go to Chi died.
Hit that shit kid.
Stuff playing around.
Some mother fuckers want to come down and stay sober.
Going small kind of shit is this,
get some of that Daryl,
stop.
Darryl stops playing around your round.
Everyone needs fucking around down.
Darrell just have a little,
it's better for you.
I'm telling you,
you'll see the world in a better light.
Good light.
Don't be scared of weed bro.
It's on sale.
I took a little pussy like Nick Diaz says,
don't be scared homie.
The reason I quit the wheat him and really it's not.
It's not because,
you know,
it's a fear thing and thing like that.
And I just,
the last time I think it was,
it was my old boxing trainer and he was leaving the gym and I was like,
oh,
okay.
And you know,
he wanted to smoke.
So I was like,
it's like a little bonding session that we have.
And so we smoked out and then after we were done smoking out,
I mean,
he's a stoner and I forget,
he's totally used to it.
So he's just like,
all right,
get out of my truck.
And I'm like,
you can leave me alone.
I'm just high as shit.
I ended up going home,
eating all my food and I watched America's got talent for an hour and a half and
then I woke up going,
that was the most useless fucking night of my life.
I mean,
I just,
I'm still testing,
sorry.
And American Eagle apartments,
like I should have gone and tried to do something that,
that ruined you.
This one time was smoking weed and I'd stopped years before,
but then I went back and I was like,
well,
that was dumb.
It was just like for real,
it's not for everybody,
but a lot of people they give it up too quick.
No,
I was just telling him this be before we went on.
I'm like,
someday I probably will go back to smoking weed because I don't find nothing
wrong with it is just at the time where I'm at right now I'm on grind mode so
it's like,
oh,
I don't have time to just be high.
You know what I'm saying?
It depends on what you're trying to do.
You know?
Some people are trying to get high because I just want to get fucked up,
not,
I just want to kick back and they just want to just chill out and get fucked up
and just sort of skate their life away and just like,
but we'd makes me more ambitious and I don't know about,
you know,
but we'd makes me like realize like,
damn,
I've got to get some shit done hour now
Garrett to be more ambitious than I am.
Are you really ambitious?
It's like,
but not,
not in a,
not in a Hollywood type of way.
Just type of like a life type of way.
Like it's so much like,
it's so much stuff that I'm using comedy for in my life,
you know what I mean?
More than just more than just like TV or some shit like that is just,
you know,
look comedy.
Sometimes it's penance.
I look at it as,
as penance.
Oh yeah.
What do you mean I've done some evil shit.
Comedy is somehow or another your,
your punishment for doing this?
No,
like penance as far as payback for the evil shit that I've done.
Making people laugh.
Yeah.
Laugh.
It's like Paris or like,
is that the right word?
Not Quite.
Maybe.
I see what you're saying though.
Whatever the word is.
I know exactly what you're saying.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
You guess
you were right about bleeding.
Guess you were right about me saying that I was smart because I'm using the
wrong fucking worlds and there,
yeah,
that's all.
Well,
you're not a dumb guy,
man.
You know it's match to leash and prop Ameesh said that in a black voice.
Racist.
Fuck.
No,
but it's like,
like,
um,
uh,
like,
for instance,
um,
I was lucky enough to get with the managers that I got.
You already know who they are,
but it's who's your manager?
Oh,
you just,
I don't pay attention to shit.
I'm mad.
It's about by George Carlin's manager,
man.
Jay Hamza.
Wow.
I like got with them.
That's pretty huge.
Yeah.
And it's like dog.
So as far as me being,
what kind of advice they give you dog,
it sucks for me.
Can you lighten your skin and no,
it's,
I can do a clean set.
No,
it's actually just the opposite man.
Blacker.
No,
not to get a Tan.
not even nigger it up a little dog.
I've actually had people tell me that damn dog tell you I've had it,
dude.
Tell me.
Right there was a manager that told me,
cause I do shit based on the news and Shit.
And he was like,
you know what?
You really should stop reading the newspaper because black people don't read
newspapers.
And I'm like,
what?
Well,
who told you this dog?
It's a fucking agent that Toby,
I've heard some of the worst advice ever from agents and managers.
Here's my favorite.
Kevin James old manager said,
Kevin,
when you lose weight,
you're losing rules.
He told him to not lose weight because if you lose weight,
you're gonna lose parts.
You won't be able to go out for for roles.
You won't be the fat guy like you fuck being healthy.
You're not capable of doing it on your own.
You're here and you're going to get lucky.
Exactly.
We're not going to find some special town you.
He also said that he would never be the lead in anything you're going to
understand just because of your body talking to him.
There would be the lead.
Meanwhile,
the fuck man was on King of Queens or seven years is in movies and make hundreds
of millions.
I just shut the fuck up.
It's just,
it's always added but is always the motherfuckers.
They can't do it that tell you what you,
you can't do.
They make.
See there's the reason being is they make money from you and they want to figure
out what is the way they can make the most money from you.
What is the way you're going to be the most successful?
And they think that they can kind of mold you and get you to become something
that you're not in.
That thing will be more successful,
but they don't understand.
You'll never achieve greatness.
Not that we ever will,
but you know,
I mean you'd never hit the zone instead of achieve greatness.
It sounds very grandiose and I never think about myself that way honestly.
But I do think of hitting the zone and I think you can't hit the zone if you're
trying to pretend to be something that you're not or you're putting on some sort
of an act.
I think you hit the zone when you have like the purest expression of,
of,
of your thoughts on stage in an entertaining form.
He said,
you are your real thoughts.
It's not like cause you cause you to get someone to like you more or you know
you're not dressed.
I've done that before,
dressed away to get people to like,
cause you cause you touch people
and more of an authentic type of way if it's you,
you know what I'm saying?
What you feel when you touch the people.
It's the only way you really touched them.
Yeah.
Like and APP and just the opposite with my manager is he has so much money from
Carlin that he's not really in a hurry to make money,
which sucks for me,
but oh well cause he,
cause he doesn't like this is,
this is probably listening right now.
This is one of his favorite sayings cause I was like,
you know,
it was some stuff happening and I,
it was some stuff that I wanted to try out for and he was like,
Ugh,
that's not good for your career in the long haul.
And I'm like,
well I need the money.
And he's like,
will you stop thinking like a,
like a broke ass Nigga and think
yeah,
ass nigger.
Yes.
Wow.
Maybe he just took you on it just so he could use those words.
Welcome fetish.
It's his giant woman.
No cause it's like,
no
and and he's,
and he's right.
What was it that he told you not to do?
I wanted to try out to try to do def jam [inaudible] jam.
I like comedy central and he was like,
no,
you aren't going to do that shit.
You aren't?
Yeah.
He's like,
you aren't going to dumb down your,
your comedy to be on this bullshit.
Here's,
here's the deal,
dude.
You don't have to dumb it down.
You just have to do your best shit just to do some shit is tight or some shit
that's funny and tight.
You don't,
he's silly.
What?
But what wound up happening is I wound up getting this special on showtime
instead.
That's uncensored.
That's basically me doing a spot.
That's me.
It's everything that I do.
Which is,
what is that for?
Oh,
it's on next Saturday.
April 23rd on showtime.
It's actually with Jon Lovitz.
Okay.
Is it a what?
What is this is John Leverage presents.
Oh,
okay.
It's a bunch of comics.
Yeah,
it's me,
Quinn,
Dale and he and back.
Okay.
Nine.
Yeah.
It's going to be fun,
man.
And it's like uncensored is all of us doing 15 with John each and shit.
And um,
but here's the thing about def jam too,
just to counter your,
your,
your managers.
What he said Dave Chappelle did,
did def jam.
Okay.
Yeah,
but that wouldn't mean that would mean it was necessary though.
Joe.
Didn't everybody do def jam?
That Martin Lawrence to def jam those guys?
That was when it was necessary.
Yeah,
but bro,
it doesn't matter if it's necessary on unnecessary.
It matters.
Is there a stage?
Is there a microphone?
Do you want to do it?
Do you want to do it then go do it.
Really?
Yeah.
You just doing stand up man.
Look is a fuck if it's on def jam.
It's you.
When that,
when they say ladies and gentlemen,
Dow,
right,
and you take that microphone,
it doesn't fucking matter if it's on def jam or if it's on anything.
It's just you.
It's you with a microphone and a stage and the camera on you.
Chappelle has done a few times,
even did the poetry jam.
He's done multiple.
The poetry jam.
That was some ridiculous shit,
man.
You want to talk about some cell phone if you want to write all that sloppy but
to give me some fucking laughs in there.
I am a strong woman.
Grow up in the,
by the time I was six strong,
good.
By the time I was eight iron instead I am what?
I am.
Rise from the fire flames inside of me wanting to burst out,
not wanting to accept my lower class.
Got,
I just made that shit up.
You can go up there and you could write those.
They're easy and they're stupid.
Stop it.
Why is it,
why did it shut up?
Why is it always the light switch was always the light skin.
Black people that write the fucking cause.
They're confusing white mom and a black dad and the white mom is really into
yoga and Tofu.
Black Dad didn't want to stick around as a lot of issues.
You can't really quite rock bread dreadlocks.
She tries but she got up there with the nose ring.
It's spit out that fucking poetry jam 40 that's bullshit.
I should clarify.
I'm bullshitting.
Mostly I'm just playing around because there's something,
I went to a poetry jam breeding wants in Venice and it was kind of interesting.
There was a few people that were legit.
It's like they have that sort of legit thoughts,
you know,
it's like most poetry you saying well what is it?
It's it's horse shit.
It's like it's a bunch of self indulgent,
you know,
wishy washy nonsense.
But then you read like Bukowski,
Bukowski had some poetry that you're like,
whoa.
Like he had a great fucking story about taking a shit,
having a beer shit and his wallet falling into the Shit.
And it was really fucking funny.
But it was basically poetry.
I mean it was poetry and these little little short stories.
Did you ever write poetry too?
Like women are ex girlfriends or anything like that?
Cause I would die out.
Pay Money to read one of your fucking phones.
Good.
Probably.
So I must have,
I can't remember specific.
I know I left some weak ass voicemails.
Oh right.
Well you were,
you're a kid.
First of all,
you get dumped and you don't want to accept it and you want to figure out
there's gotta be a way to get this chip bag.
And so he started trying to pretend and trying to like manipulate the,
you know the situation and pretend you have feelings other than the ones that
you do cause you think it wasn't moving.
It was not even that he wants a pussy.
I think it's like your self esteem doesn't want to accept this person doesn't
like anymore and she just start pretending to be somebody who you're not so
natural,
you know,
so be at one point in time it becomes a game.
It's like,
you know when you teach a chimp that if he puts a bunch of little pegs in order
than a piece of fruit comes out.
Well that chimps going to figure that that's his reward thing,
you know for for a dude,
like you start getting pussy and you start getting love and then all of a sudden
this person breaks up.
Like what little buttons do I have to press to get my apple bank?
You know it's like song once for a check.
I don't play any fucking fucking song.
I didn't know cause it was so unlike me like non top.
Can you talk about it on stage?
Oh my God,
I have to start cause I mean no good.
I never had to sing it.
I swear to God I could've sworn at the time I was thinking like,
well if she sees this come out of me,
I'll just sing it to her without me fucking instruments
and so fucking thankful I never got around to sing in that song.
Is there any one thing in life that's more embarrassing than a song that you
sing to a tells
you that song socks and
you write a song and he'd go,
listen,
if you don't talk to me after today and for the rest of your life,
I just want you to know that I wrote this for you to sit down,
please listen to this.
And then at the end she's like,
that was fucking terrible.
I'm so glad I had dumped you.
You are sad,
pathetic.
Fuck you made a shit of soil for me.
You asked him like,
man,
Shit,
now I'm on some man.
I'm going to put that on my Wikipedia.
Somebody I know.
By the way,
I've never edited my Wikipedia.
I don't touch it.
I'll never even read it.
I don't correct bad things.
So if you want to just make some shit up,
if you want to look put,
please feel free.
But I want that on there,
Joe.
Rosa,
man,
Shit,
I'm on some mad shit.
Okay,
now
that's just my only request.
I have to write any credits and they don't really have to make a t shirt that
says I'm on some manage.
I don't have crones disease either.
So please stop email.
Yes,
fellow crones sufferers.
I appreciate your illness,
but I just,
I feel bad that all these people think that I have because
Ricky Pedia,
they just make shit up Wikipedia.
It also says Brian Collins,
my brother,
you know was,
I don't change it.
He's my brother.
As far as I'm concerned,
I've had like 10 Wikipedia is and they automatically get could just get to lead
it because it's the most retarded shit.
Like there's not even a one sentence that was ever real and then it doesn't want
worst.
The absolute worst is when you know a dude wrote his own Wikipedia.
Is there anything creepy or in life and reading some dudes thing like you know,
and an honored and cherished member of the comedy community.
He has been yelling,
dude,
fuck yeah,
they do to fuck.
Yeah,
they do.
Yeah.
I've,
I've read sports casters that I'm known like colic,
fight commentators that I know.
They wrote their own shit.
I've read it for Comedians.
I know they wrote their own shit.
You read and you're like,
what the fuck is this nonsense breath of fresh air in a stagnant comedy
community
food when you're talking about what am I doing wrong where I would never do no
shit like what are you doing?
Right?
Of course you wouldn't do that.
That's insane.
Listen man,
you,
you got to spend as little time as possible like projecting who you want people
to think you are.
Do that shit through your work.
If you've got somebody that wants to write a bio for you or you,
if you write a bio of your own,
it better be silly dog blowing yourself up.
I know third time on stage I let to present or no,
this was going to be the next big star of comedy.
I sh I held myself to up to that standard.
I've had it ever since.
That would be hilarious.
That's actually what I'm going through right now is like this management team.
They want me to help write a bio and I'm like,
what the fuck am I supposed to say man?
Well,
you know,
I mean look,
you should help write it because it's your [inaudible].
Am I supposed to say?
I don't know why some are low funny man.
Just be funny about it.
Just look,
if you're going to write a bio man,
this is why I say if you're a calm,
I don't,
I didn't write my bio.
My Bio is written by someone else and it's embarrassing and I don't like
taekwondo stuff there and I was shit that
I would never put in there.
If I was going to rewrite my bio,
I would definitely have to make it funny.
You have to make it silly.
As silly as possible.
He'll make up some shit,
make up some shit about unicorn wrestling.
You know whatever the fuck you're going to do.
But when you read,
when you read someone's like really self congratulatory bio's and how they
really view themselves like,
oh it's disgusting.
You can't even enjoy them on stage cause you think all this guy's doing is he
just wants you to think he's
jacking himself off for one of the most unpleasant things is someone who takes
himself way too seriously.
That's insane up there.
You know,
trying to make you laugh and there everything's a joke.
I said to them,
how about comics that try shit out on you?
Hey man,
how about this bit?
I'm thinking about doing it whole stage.
Hey folks,
have you ever known?
Is that when you,
you know like trying to on you,
you know what,
what,
what?
What are suffer from is I hate when you're off stage and you can tell it's
coming.
Yeah.
I'm saying this isn't a conversation.
This is a setup,
like you got your set up,
he's faking a conversation and to get to his job.
Exactly.
And you're like,
motherfucker,
you practicing materials on me?
Yeah.
At least if like you're a comic and you say,
Hey dude,
I've got a problem with this bit,
Tuck it back.
Exactly.
That's kind of get out of this book,
you know.
I mean we all have bits,
right?
Don't you have a bit,
I mean I,
I've had a few bits where I'm like,
Damn,
how do I get out of this motherfucker?
Like I got all these laughs but uh,
how do I get out of this?
There's no way to get out of it.
It's like a segway where is it just ends on a cliff and then you,
you sometimes you can do it.
That's good.
See that's why.
That's why I really don't hang out as much.
Like you see me at comedy clubs,
but I believe know,
hang out with like a whole bunch of comics because it's like,
I like real conversations.
Like I like going to bars and just hanging out and stuff like that and just
talking to people.
You can have real conversations with comics.
It's just not on,
you got to find the right call me.
See this is,
this is,
this is what happened to me.
Like when I moved out to Los Angeles,
like you,
you and some other comics and guys were,
were we're lucky cause you have comics in your class per se.
It's like dudes that you came up through the rights.
Well I moved out to La and I was in a weird circumstance cause I was like kind
of by myself moving out here by myself.
I really didn't fit in on open mic circuit but I wasn't a headliner.
So I was right in the middle because I had spent so much time in New York kind
of getting seasoned.
So I wasn't quite an open miker as far as my skill,
but as far as my notoriety.
But I wasn't a headliner cause I didn't have that type of pool.
So I was really stuck in the middle of some shit.
And then you have classes of comics that all grew up together,
so I really can't bounce shit off of.
I know what you're saying.
You know,
so was hard.
It was really good.
Like that's the one thing,
that's the one thing that I wished that I had come to la earlier or maybe later,
not when I did,
is because if I come earlier,
I would have group of people,
you know what I'm saying?
You have that group,
the name,
she never think like that.
He came at the exact right time for you.
We can't ever think like that.
You know,
there's a self defeating thoughts like that don't get you anywhere.
I'm like,
man,
if I had just come this,
you know,
it's good to be around a group of people,
but it's also good to be around some people that are way ahead of you and your,
your force,
you're forced to pick up the pace and celebrate to their frequency has been
lucky.
I've been lucky as hell on that level
because,
and that goes back to to the competition aspect of me.
It's like,
um,
uh,
just as far as man working with you,
I've done shows with Bill Burgess thought well fucking fire as comics and it's
like dog.
It's just these dudes are so tight that it's just like,
it makes you look at your own shit and say,
I gotta tighten this shit up.
That's what,
that's what I'm supposed to be doing.
Not the jokes,
but that's how it's supposed to be and this is what I'm doing so I'm doing
something wrong.
You know what I mean?
Right.
I know what you mean.
It's like that type of shit.
Yeah,
that's,
that's one of the best things about being around a high level comedians like in
La,
like you get to see like real high level stuff and be inspired by it and it
makes your own,
like you recognize what you like about that,
you know,
like what does it old man,
he's got like very little time in between his punchlines.
You hit you hard with it and then like,
oh,
you know,
you,
you see that.
You're like,
what am I enjoying and how come I'm not my pace?
I need to pick my pace up.
I need to do this.
Maybe I have too many words in these jokes.
Maybe you know,
maybe it's a,
you know,
so that it's,
it's fine.
Yeah.
And then the whole,
the whole one thing that really trips me out about you is,
and I'll tell him that dog is so cool to know Joe because the funny part is he
doesn't have to be funny,
but he works at being funny.
Like,
like,
like looking at all these stars,
doing comedy nowadays.
Like you,
you could go out just as the UFC dude and make money.
I mean that's not you,
but you could do that.
But like for you to even bother to work at this craft and,
and actually be funny and work at it though,
that says something about your personality dog because you really don't got to
do it.
But I do because it's,
it's what makes me better at everything I do.
It makes me,
it makes me a better commentator.
You know,
being,
doing standup I think makes me better as a human being.
It makes me,
it forces me to think about things when a whole nother level,
it forces me to consider every single angle of every single subject,
whether it's something that's going on nuclear problem in China or you know,
financial bullshit,
whatever the fuck it is.
When I'm,
when you're a comic man,
you,
you start probing things.
Not just because you're curious about it,
but also because like,
what,
is there a joke in here in which the angle of this fucking thing,
what's wrong?
How could this have been avoided?
Well,
what the fuck?
How come they didn't do that?
There's a joke.
You know what I mean?
Like that's,
that's a lot of times
landed my,
it's really expanded my view on life.
Yeah.
And just a lot of fun.
You'll do it forever,
but whatever else comes,
that's the one thing you'll realize is that comedy is the most fun.
It's the most rewarding.
And like even a fucking hundred people are at 80 tomorrow night or tonight
rather.
We're doing south comedy hall.
There'll be 80 people there tonight.
You come in,
you're going do it.
Yeah.
It's awesome place.
Southcom he holds his shit.
If you never been were there tonight where they're almost every Wednesday,
I won't be there next week,
but almost every Wednesday it's on Melrose Street and it's this fun little tight
ass club.
And we go in there and when we,
when we fuck around and it's,
here's my point,
what the hell was I talking about before
as far as expanding your mind as far as how you think and then doing comedy
forever.
And that's the most fun that you had.
Yeah,
it's the most fun.
It's the point was,
yeah,
it doesn't matter if it's ADP boat or if it's fucking,
you know,
Toronto,
April 29th I'm doing this 2,500 people,
you know,
it's almost sold out to 2,500 fucking people.
I did 1800 in Seattle.
It's a,
you know,
you do these giant fucking shows.
There are fun as shit,
but guess what?
It's also fun to do 50 fucking people.
It's fun.
It's fun to do a late night show.
You stop in on a Wednesday night at the Improv and you'd go on last and it's the
10:00 PM show and there's a hundred people in that audience and they're tired
and it's still fun as shit.
It doesn't matter if it's on television,
it doesn't.
When you start getting good at comedy,
you will realize that that is the number one fun thing to do as an entertainer.
So all my other shit that I do,
I kind of do like also,
but if I had to choose one,
it would,
I was thinking like it for sure.
Like if like if somebody took everything away and said,
all you
do is one thing,
we wouldn't even be close.
There's,
I wouldn't say there's no way I would just do commentating for the UFC because
I'm a fucking fan of fighting of,
of MMA.
I would be a fan just as big if I never worked with UFC a day in my life.
If tomorrow do,
UFC called me up and said,
go fuck yourself were higher and Mario Lopez
getting old,
dude,
it's over.
If they,
if they did that and I'd be like,
all right,
I guess I'm just watching on TV from now on.
It'd be,
I would watch the same amount of fights.
I wouldn't be there for the prelims cause I wouldn't see the live shows.
Dude,
I probably watched the same amount of televised.
So that's,
that's,
that's like,
and that's one of the theories that I've always had is like,
Doug,
I want to do this for the rest of my life.
So that's why I guess you were an artist.
You know,
I'm,
I guess that's why I'm not really in a hurry for a lot of things.
Like this is going to be my,
my,
my first TV credit of any kind ever.
Man,
we'll make you better at everything else you try to do to see if you want to try
to do something else.
Like say if you try to,
one day you want to host a talk show or one day you want to do some other kind
of a television show,
you're going to get better at it because you're a comic.
It makes you,
it's the hardest.
It's the most rewarding,
but it's also the most difficult form in my opinion of of talking.
So how do you like feel about these,
these dudes that just run out here cause they and put together the comedy
towards just because
I think as I've gotten older,
one thing that I've gotten really good at is finding who to get mad at and who
it's a waste of time to get mad at.
And one of the things it's a waste of time to get mad at.
It's some person just trying to make it,
what does,
who gives a,
who gives a fuck what they're doing,
whether they're doing some stupid fucking game show on television like I did,
whether they're doing,
you know,
they're,
they're trying to do stand up comedy when they're 37 years old and they're just
coming off a sitcom and they never done standup ever.
It would it just fucking look at Charlie Murphy,
who's a good of mine match Holly Murphy.
I admire the fuck out of what he did.
He would,
Charlie,
Charlie Murphy jumped right in as a headliner.
Right.
Then he went,
he and I went on the road.
We did 22 gigs together.
Okay.
And this guy had only been doing comedy for like a couple of years.
Right?
Two years.
We're doing thousands of cedars,
you know,
20002000500 seaters,
giant fucking places.
And Charlie's going on after me and I'm doing an hour,
I'm doing an hour,
we're,
we're co headlining.
Oh,
we did this.
We went back and forth and back and forth.
That mother fucker's got balls.
He just jumped into the fire.
So I mean,
you know,
these people go,
these fucking goes,
hey,
they think you're a comic.
You're not a comic yet.
Yo,
Dr Dies trying to be a comic and so is Steve Steevo and so is,
you know,
other people that they get into it,
man,
it's fun.
There's room for more.
Everybody can be a comic.
No,
it can be an 80 year old doctor and one day you decide,
you know what,
I want to do some fucking stand up and I'll tell you what.
If you go on stage and you kick some ass,
comics will take you right in,
right?
Don't you see that?
Like will like you and I,
when we met,
here's the language that we understood.
You're funny.
I'm a comic.
You're calm.
Like this kid's a comic.
He's fucking funny.
Boom,
you're in.
You know that's how it is.
But a real comics don't ever like say,
Oh,
this guy's a headliner,
but this guy's an opener.
We can't talk to him and would real comics you're in when you're in.
Yeah.
Funny is funny,
but that's the,
that's the,
that's the thing that I think helped me out a lot is when I stopped getting mad
at everybody.
At the end of the day,
I'm still a comedy fan,
man.
I love a good,
even if they serve a good land,
if they suck,
just don't listen.
Just get out of the room when they're on stage.
Right.
There's guys that suck.
Man.
I can't watch them on stage cause it hurts my head.
You know what I'm saying?
Like,
you know,
it hurts what what they're doing is so out of whack and it's not funny.
And so unaware.
It almost like screws up my sense of comedy and I get confused and I don't want
to go on stage and have,
when you're on stage,
man,
if you're,
there's a person on stage and they're really rocking it,
you get into their mind,
man,
you were on their frequency,
whether it's,
you know,
Joe Diaz or Louie Ck,
Louis Ck is a great example of that.
He's a great comic.
But one of the things he does,
it's really great is he pulls you into the way he's thinking.
You know,
he pulls you in to how he's looking things and you start thinking the way he
thinks as he's doing it.
And it's hilarious.
And that's one of the,
but when someone's got some whack ass thoughts and there unedited and they're
sloppy and they're stupid and the shit they're saying makes no fucking sense and
it's all shut up.
That's gotta leave the room.
But you can't be mad at him.
The Guy who trying to do his thing,
he just can't do it.
Oh No.
I used to get mad at them.
I used to get mad at people.
That sucked.
I used to get mad at,
especially if there were more successful than me,
I would get mad.
I am,
I am so glad that I'm past that because I had a problem with,
if I'm onstage and I'm bitter,
I suck.
As long as I'm having fun,
I'm good.
Like we're not necessarily fine,
but as long as you know,
I had to take the bitterness out of my act because it was funny,
but it wasn't.
It was like people were like,
that might be too much.
Right.
So once I got that bitterness out where you know what to each his own and just
like you were saying is wrong for all of us.
But I just wish that,
you know,
like for instance,
one of my big pet peeves is I wish that white comics could see whatever they
want to because that would free black comics up in a way.
And I know it sounds crazy,
but
boy,
why comics to pretty much say whatever they want.
Yeah,
but y'all don't,
y'all can't say the n word.
You can't say fat like,
well,
you can't get away with no one.
I can get away with saying Faggot a lot easier than your average white comic
could just cause I'm a black guy.
Disagree.
When Jim Norton says Faggot,
it comes out.
It's like poetry,
music.
True.
Well,
there's,
I mean,
but that's put,
but that's one of the baddest comics going I'm talking
was he's a real comic anyway,
but even,
sorry,
black comics can say faggot and not have a point and they don't get in any type
in trouble or it's not a trial type of trouble board.
They do do as the audience loses a little bit of respect for him,
especially if it doesn't belong.
If it doesn't go on what they're saying,
if they just didn't have a shotgun or they're doing it,
it's an ignorant with things that they're saying.
They're saying you lose value with the audience.
You lose a,
they don't respect the connection that you've made.
They'll let you keep going,
but there's lost,
lost a piece of respect.
And that's really what's going on,
man.
If you,
if you go up there with your thoughts,
your thoughts are,
you know,
you,
you have to hone them down to the,
to the,
the best of your abilities to get them into these people's minds with the most,
the less,
the least ego possible,
the most amount of respect for the person's attention span and the most amount
of focus on the material,
like the most,
so that you can hit po points and notes and have ideas that they didn't come up
with.
Like they didn't even say,
wow,
I never even looked at it that way.
That's one of the best things about comedy,
man.
When someone makes you laugh about some shit and then they point out one thing
and you're like,
fuck it,
that's so true,
man.
That is so ridiculous.
They have,
why are they doing that?
You know,
what the fuck?
Why aren't they,
why aren't they doing this?
Just like,
I'm just like,
what happens with me a lot of times is like you,
um,
I'll,
I'll talk about jail but I also talk.
Yeah.
How do you bring that up?
I'm going to shut a crack head
basically.
Well it actually comes after me talking about,
well it actually talks about me paying paying taxes now,
which is,
which is a concept that is fascinating to me.
Like I just started paying taxes like three years ago and this whole tax payer
concept fascinates me and people find it weird.
But what you got to understand his dog,
you don't pay taxes on a dope money.
So it's like
worried though that they're gonna come after you for now that you talk about it
on stage and shit the one day the IRS ago,
listen,
you owe us money from selling coke.
Come and get it.
Cause I don't know how much I fucking made.
And they don't,
they go bring crackheads and bring them in the courtroom.
They would never be able to talk about that.
They bought off.
I bought $1 million half of crack off motherfucker.
Really?
Where did you get to rob a bank?
And this is my fucking,
show me your main downswing.
That's the beauty of comments and Louis in June.
Now the speech as a joke
and then,
but that's where the whole,
that's where the whole thing about going to jail comes in is after I talk about
paying taxes now
can you go to jail for two years for shooting somebody?
What's that all about?
Because of the intent.
It was oil.
Yeah,
it was,
well,
I mean you weren't trying to kill the guy.
I can't really talk about this.
Okay,
well I proved that I can put it like that word,
put it like this.
They never found a gun.
So it was one of those things where the guy knew that I shot him,
but they never found the gun and everybody it's you say I didn't shoot him.
I didn't bother.
That was,
that was me making a deal.
Like I wasn't going to fight this shit too.
Two fucking years for shooting somebody.
It's pretty fucking good.
So I just took the deal.
I'm like,
fuck that I can do to,
I'm not,
what is it like doing two years in the pokey dog?
It's fucking,
did you see a lot of rape?
Yes.
Really?
Yeah.
What happened?
What'd you say?
What's that smell?
Just fucking
great.
Well,
well,
well not like,
not like,
not like rate,
but just motherfuckers given up that ass,
like just,
yeah,
it was just,
it was just accepted.
Like for some motherfuckers,
like a lot of it is,
I was just thinking,
coming up here,
I remember playing a game of space,
right?
I was,
I was playing a space game hard.
Yeah.
Cars phase.
Please let him win at the end of this game.
And then,
no,
no.
And then,
and then there was a dude sitting to my left,
like Joe is another dude walked up behind him,
tapped him on the shoulder,
do got up,
pulled his pants down,
and then it went to his cell.
Cause that,
cause it's time,
you know what I'm saying?
It's just time for you to get.
Fuck,
Whoa,
whoa.
So the guy comes over taps,
dude,
you're playing cards to this dude and what does the guy live there is,
who are you guys like blessing upon?
Nothing crazy.
None of that shit taps him.
And the guy just pulls his pants down before he starts walking.
So to let everybody know this is what's going on.
Like he's drowning that.
I guess it's just the way he do it,
I guess the way,
I guess that was his choice.
But he just goes in there,
pulls his pants down.
And the guy who started fucking him in front of everybody.
Well he,
well he went into the cell like he had a,
he had a cell over there,
but he went into itself,
got done.
So the cells,
a lot of times the cells are open and everybody's just wandering around.
Fuck.
Yeah.
So it's like prison.
How much time are you wondering around?
Um,
okay.
You got count like three times.
Well,
the jails I was in,
we had account four times a day.
So unless you had somebody do something stupid on what they call it,
the tier you be out for the rest of that day and sell.
It was either time to go to lunch,
dinner,
hang out all day.
Yeah.
So basically the jail is like,
you got a cell and the cells open most of the time and you guys are just
wandering around playing checkers and doing over the fuck you want tickling each
sucking dicks.
I was always curious about this and then,
you know,
family members and I've never been able to ask him exactly like as far as the
prison rules,
what's the socially acceptable allotment of time that you gotta be in there
before?
It's just socially acceptable to start another dude.
Well,
if you go in there for life,
well,
life,
everything.
We never thought we'd do
like,
uh,
well I can't speak for every jail,
but all I do know is where did you go to jail?
I was in jail in DC and then Maryland and then,
uh,
I was in Baltimore city.
They moved you around?
Yeah.
Wow.
And um,
I can't speak for every jail.
Why they move you did you do some gangster shit?
No,
cause it was,
well I actually went to solitary for 45 days for tickling.
No,
not particular player.
Uh,
cause that's the first time you've ever said that,
that if you take a look,
yeah,
that's a rare
combination to
you're now you're taking them player,
particular player.
Yeah.
That's a very rare statement.
That's a hardcore state.
We right there.
Oh No.
But okay.
I went in right and I had some shoes,
tennis shoes and these dudes,
one of them.
And I had to fight them every day to keep my fucking shoes.
And then I got sick of fighting these guys.
So I had a bright idea that instead of fight,
now I'll just hit the COO.
So niggas would think that I'm crazy.
Right.
Well I did that.
And what happened was they got these people called this did,
they got these cops called the storm troopers.
Like they'll run into the tear in riot gear if anything break out,
like full riot gear,
fucking all that shit.
I hate to see yo and these dudes roll in.
And when I woke up,
I was in the infirmary.
I had broken ribs,
like they fucked me up.
Damn.
So when I got out of the infirmary,
they sent me to solitary for 45 days.
You should have asked somebody about that plan.
Looked to who am I gonna talk to my lonely.
At first I'm thinking about going crazy and fucking up a cup.
I didn't have a chance to fuck him up.
I,
I hit that cop one time.
Just a body shot.
Just some niggas think dog before.
I think I drew my fish back.
I had like 10 motherfuckers there.
Right.
Take your shoes after that.
Yeah,
no,
no.
Oh the cops fuck me up.
But people thought I was nuts.
And it's like,
but the whole,
the whole,
so they leave you alone.
And then once I,
once you have accomplished the same thing by kicking the shit out of one of the
guys who took your sneakers.
Not every day.
No,
no.
Nobody.
You would just poop on my shoes.
I didn't know one would want,
it doesn't work.
Brian like doesn't work in advance.
I like to wait.
You know it doesn't work when you're on ship them off.
They'll just clean it.
You're in jail.
You aren't here though.
It's like it's a whole different menu.
They'll just clean them off.
Big Deal.
Yeah.
The clean that shit out fucking s like rub it into the inside of Martin.
Cause of cause of my balls on the outside.
No,
it always kills me.
He is,
whenever somebody saying how they,
how they would survive in jail is always wrong.
It's Paul Ryan has a way to get away from
rape.
Yeah.
Brian.
Some guys trying to make me suck his dick.
I'll just grab his balls and run as fast as I can in the opposite direction.
The brick off the bucking balls off.
Feels like he can dig my nails in there.
Grab a thing or two and just fucking power.
Where are you going to go when you run away?
Huh?
I'm going to be ripping his balls and wearing it as a mess down the fucking
whatever it's called.
The stairway and tomorrow I will have that mask on my head still and no one will
fuck with me cause I'll rip your balls off.
But there's tomorrow mask and guess what guys starts in front of me,
I'll take it.
There's no happy end of this conversation
for our listeners right now are hemorrhaging.
They're in the car.
Shot him the fuck up.
I swear to God,
I'll unsubscribe to this fucking stupid podcast.
This ridiculous by hurting fucked here.
This ridiculous idea.
Nobody's [inaudible] podcasts ago.
It's still just as good as this is idea.
It's look what he's going to do.
It's his plan.
God bless you.
But you never know man.
You might have a killer grip.
I did.
Some dudes have a grip.
It's very shocking.
Every now and then like you do Jujitsu with the guy grabs your wrist and go,
God damn,
this motherfucker's got a grip.
You know it can't even fuck
some guys.
Some guys can hold on to your man Brian.
Maybe may Brian's got that kind of grip.
I hope so.
Cause that shit.
Well listen,
at least he's got a plan plan plan.
No one else.
No one a much better plan is don't fucking go to jail.
I was like,
the absence heath is this Japanese nuclear power plant?
Is that the worst plan that human beings have ever made as far as like plans
that didn't work out,
plans that were chuge disaster here.
Is there a single worst plan?
Then building a nuclear reactor on a fucking a monkey making aids.
I don't think that's how it's happened,
but I don't think I'd be really fucked him.
Uncle Sam Kinison,
did they actually know that that shit was on a fault line?
Oh,
for sure.
So he built it to last to take it up to an 8.2 they thought that was pretty
generous.
You know,
that's kind of extravagant earthquake.
They got a fucking nine after yesterday's podcasts.
A lot of people are saying that it's not as bad in Japan as everyone is saying.
That's nonsense.
That's not true at all.
They've just updated it to Chernobyl status.
They've just,
it's bad.
Here's the thing about it being bad.
It's not getting better.
Okay.
It's getting better maybe in a hundred thousand years and it's getting more and
more fucked up and more and more nuclear materials is leaking.
The reason why the it keeps getting worse and now it's level seven Chernobyl
levels is because it's getting worse.
It's not.
It's like,
well it's going to get to a certain point then it's just going to stop.
Oh this is a bad situation.
It's bad.
And in Japan,
Japan is not big man.
It's not big.
It's not like this shit is happening in Nebraska and you're living in Alaska and
it never really hits,
you know,
this is Japan is fucking tiny man.
It's just so nice place.
So let me take a wild guess.
They built it on a fault because the land was cheap
or whatever.
So they decided to build all of Japan prime.
I mean,
Japan is an island,
you know,
and it's not that big.
So there's a lot of spots in Japan where the fucking ground moves.
Like what are you gonna do?
You can just going to hope that you've got it figured,
figured out where it doesn't go bad if the ground moves.
But they never knew the ground was going to go to a nine I mean nine for five
minutes.
I mean,
it just broke everything and then the tsunami came in and killed the generators
and they couldn't cool the look the rods down and cut a break there.
Did they just no.
Yeah,
but they didn't plan it out.
Well,
it's like one of the worst plans ever.
We're going to create an a,
a some sort of a reactor that harnesses the power of the fucking Sun,
but we don't know how to shut it off.
Just in case we don't know.
We don't know what happens if the power goes out of the power.
We're good for about eight hours.
The power goes out.
They had battery backup for eight hours.
Does that?
Yeah.
So in those eight hours,
you got a fucking,
okay,
how,
how fucking greedy are these motherfuckers like nobody.
Nobody thought like,
Hey,
it's not possible for acceptable risks.
They were willing to take what they felt were acceptable risks and the
acceptable risk just really aren't that planned out.
It's human beings have such a narrow,
we have such a narrow window of reference because our lives are only 30 40 50
years.
By the time we're making these choices,
you don't learn that much in those 50 years.
You don't,
you just don't.
And then when you add those 50 years to all of the fucking,
the,
the previous people that have lived to be 50 60 years old in human history and
all they figured out and you're at the forefront of it and you've created this
new thing called nuclear power and you're the guy who's like,
you know,
people are listening to Neil,
like,
how do we do this?
Well,
this is what we do when we got this thing and it cools the rods.
What happens when it goes off?
Well,
don't worry.
We've got fail safes.
Everything's got be fine.
Okay,
this guy says it's good.
Let's go with him.
Well,
he's a clueless fuck.
Just like were all clueless flux interrupt for about what one human lifetime.
We don't have enough fucking nuclear power.
Is Clean,
safe energy sometimes yes,
sometimes.
And sometimes he eats a whole through the earth.
And kills everything within a hundred miles,
you know?
Yeah.
Sometimes it's fucked.
I hate to sound like a dick head,
but like how does that affect us?
Effects us very badly because first of all,
there's,
there's power,
there's nuclear reactors in Orange County and they're on fault lines and
anything over an 8.2 shit gets very tricky and you don't know what the fuck
happens if they have a big 8.2 down in fucking the oh saying and that nuclear
power plant gets fucked in,
the power can't come back on and they can't cool the rods and it just,
and it goes into a meltdown.
Well,
we're fucked.
Mexico's Fox.
San Diego's fucked.
Everyone's fucked.
You know,
the,
these,
these guys that are doing this in Japan,
they don't know how to shut this off.
And they've got engineers that are willing to risk their lives going in there
trying to shut things down.
There's over 50 guys have gone in there knowing for sure that it's a death
sentence,
knowing for sure that they're going to get cancer,
they're going to die horrible,
terrible deaths because of radiation exposure.
And they're still doing it.
They're still doing it.
They took chances.
They went there until they couldn't take it anymore and then they went to the
hospital for radiation poisoning and they're fucked and he's got until it's
going to get 100% death.
Wish it.
Guess what?
They wouldn't do that in America.
No,
I was going to do that here.
They ain't have no take that Honda
robot and make him do whatever the has to be done on the robots or retard,
bro.
You can't do shit.
He's good at like he plays basketball,
can't get him to fucking join rods and pull rocks out and robot
bunch of robots.
Well they don't really play basketball.
They have different things that they do.
Like one of them,
if you see any dribble a ball,
I think they get dance.
I can think of they could do everything and then they could throw the armature
on.
Obviously it's a programmed like if that fucker can dance,
send them down there your way down there to make it more positive eventually.
That's no doubt that's going to happen.
Eventually there's going to be a robot that can do every single thing,
any movement in articulation that a human being can.
Because look,
we know how human works.
I'm scared of that type of shit.
Hopefully that type of shit scares and that some terminator robots.
Yeah.
Not,
not necessarily robots.
It's just getting to the point where I'm that dependent on a robot.
You know what I'm saying?
Because I know,
I know that I'm lazy.
So if I had a robot to do that shit,
I would do it.
Fuck,
you know,
like do that and do that and do that.
And then it turns out I'm not doing shit no more like,
yeah.
Basically I have a wind.
Makes you think you would do that?
Cause I'm,
cause I'm fucking lazy.
But believe me,
man,
robots are expensive.
It's going to be hard to get that robot.
It's not going to be using in your lifetime.
Robots are never going to be cheap at the time.
A robots cheap,
you'll be dead
downloaded into a robot.
It'll be like that movies one little downloaded into a robot.
There's a movie that's out right now.
Uh,
trends,
trends and dent.
No transcendent man.
Yeah.
Transcendent man,
the Ray cartwheel documentary and it's out right now on iTunes.
Yeah.
Transcendent man.
I,
I watched half of it today before the podcast.
I'm going to watch the rest of it later.
It's fascinating shit.
And Rake Kurt's,
we'll is this super genius who's,
he's made a bunch of different inventions and he's like,
you know,
at the forefront of the idea of the exponential growth of technology eventually
coming to a point where there's some sort of a singularity and artificial
intelligence and uh,
potential,
uh,
like potential download of the human consciousness into computers will,
you will live forever as long as the power stays on,
as long as you know,
you can figure out a way to have a power source that is,
well,
that is a bit much for me,
man.
It's,
it's a bit much,
but it's fascinating because it's all about,
first of all it's about nanotechnology and the idea of these little tiny
computers that are going to be the size of a cell of blood,
a blood cell,
and they're going to be in your bloodstream repairing things.
And fixing cancer and doing all kinds of,
that's awesome.
Chefs this carry shit,
that type of shit that only a comedy comedy would have ever heard about this
shit cause I'm telling you as far as building my mind and expanding that shit.
Oh you don't hear about this shit when you're on the corner and in DC fucking
slinging crack is like a cubicle.
It's fucking man.
Oh technology and shit like that.
Like oh yeah.
A lot of people don't hear about stuff until the hear about
it on Twitter or they hear about it on Facebook or they hear about on this
podcast and I hear about a lot of this shit.
A lot of the things that I hear about,
like I found out the transcendent man was out.
I knew it was coming out on DVD but I thought it was like in a few months.
But it came out on iTunes first and the only reason I found out is somebody put
it up on Twitter.
I mean it's,
and I find out so much on Twitter,
so many different weird fucking interesting stories.
Welcome
cause I like follow you on Twitter and you'll be posting some shit and I'll go
to it.
And I'm like,
what in the hell?
It's like Yo,
like you'll post stories that ain't nobody would even think of.
And I'm just like,
what the fuck?
Just just from the hour we'd check it out.
But it's like,
oh,
that's a bit much.
As far as nano technology and shit like that.
Well it's,
it's what it is,
is that computers are eventually gonna get stronger and stronger and smaller and
smaller.
I mean that's just the trend they've always done and they're going to be able to
do more and more and more.
And eventually what they're going to be able to do is you're gonna be able to
figure out what are the components of a human being and how can we reproduce
that because they can make artificial flesh already.
They've already figured out a way to make artificial ham.
They've figured out a way to make artificial like,
but they've grown ears on rats ever seen that grow a human ear on a mouse as
body.
They haven't done a human.
Yeah.
They know how to do so much that eventually it's going to get better and as it
gets better,
it's going to be an artificial human beings do all those things.
They did that go was a goat or a lamb or something in Japan.
They had that Dolly the sheep.
They cloned it,
but that's not an artificial duplicate.
If they can do all of that,
then why the fuck is there still a skid row?
Well,
here's the thing,
you can do all that.
You can't fix a human's development.
Once it's developed,
that's when it's a real,
it's like fixing a dog that's already fucking crazy.
You know,
you got a dog started attacking babies and fucking bites cars and shit,
man,
try fixing that dog.
But to keep that dog from becoming that dog that you can do.
If you treat the dog with love and respect and you train them and you train him
that he's your buddy and you know,
then you've got a happy dog.
When he meets people,
they'll associate people with being happy.
You know,
it'll be like a positive experience do.
You don't have to worry about retraining them.
It's retraining people.
That's hard.
So you get to skid row,
they're already fuck.
So then would you consider somebody like me an exception to that rule that you
just made?
Well me,
I'm accepted to it too.
I wasn't a perfect human being when I was a child.
I was fucking crazy.
I was crazy through most of my,
my young twenties you know,
like legitimately crazy.
You know?
And if you,
if you know,
you look at who you are now and who you used to be and there's evolution,
but it has to be from yourself.
You have to decide to do it on your own.
It's very difficult.
You gotta be objective.
You're going to have to probably do drugs.
You're gonna have to find yourself for real need.
We won't really get there on your own.
Well,
I beg to differ a little bit.
I think that's what me being in isolation did for me when I was in jail.
Makes Sense.
Because it's not like dog,
like you have to think.
You have to,
I mean after you,
after you blame the lawyers and God and your parents,
you still got 43 days left.
So you get analyze yourself.
Here's the deal,
man,
here's the deal.
You live,
you can blame everybody for your problems in life,
but you might be right,
but you can't change that,
right?
What you can change is what you think and how you react and what power you give
other people's actions and thoughts over you right now from getting pissed off
with them.
By using that energy for yourself,
using that energy for positive shit and using that energy to try to accomplish
it
like that can either,
that could either drive you crazy or it could make you a better person.
And that's why,
you know,
I know that I brought a lot of shit on myself,
but I'm glad that I was used,
able to use the time that I was in jail to say,
dog,
you can't keep doing this dumb shit,
man.
You have to try to do something and be it.
Be at calm.
And the reason that I even bothered to think that I could be a comic is cause
that was one of my survival while I was in jail.
I've always been this size.
So I was the guy that if somebody did something or said something,
I have something quick to say.
They kept brava smiling.
Cause though that's a long time to be anywhere.
So just a smile for that one day or,
or,
or like a laugh.
Especially in jail.
It means a whole lot more than just us talking and laughing here because dog,
it's a miserable existence.
It really is.
No,
not to say that I didn't deserve to be there,
but uh,
it's for eight fucking sucks.
It's like don't let rappers fool you.
That shit sucks man.
It's nothing.
It's nothing hard about doing something stupid and winding up in jail is fucking
dumb.
It's really stupid to do something to wind up in jail and it's,
it's just fucking awful.
So
Joey Diaz has the same story then when he was in jail,
making people laugh in jails where it got him into being a standup comedian.
But he would have,
they would have like show movies,
something to move with soc.
They'd say,
coco get up there,
get up there and tell stories.
And he would get up there and he'd start making everybody laugh.
And that's like what started him off on the road to being a comic.
Oh see I,
but then,
then the other part of it,
I also stuttered.
So what would happen is he,
like if I said something that was slick,
people would laugh and sometimes I would try to talk and stutter and people
would laugh.
So either way I'm cool.
You know,
I say so.
But with that we were just that laughter man.
Like laughter is something that I think that we as comic shouldn't take for
granted.
It's a powerful thing.
Like if it,
if it can help somebody get through jail,
like la just laughing once a day.
No,
it's just very powerful.
It's a very powerful thing and I don't think about it cause it's,
it seems frivolous,
it seems like,
oh you just laughing.
You're silly.
You're a silly person.
Oh,
it's important for your health.
It really mental health also.
It's like,
oh,
some,
some shit.
Just fucking let it ride,
man.
Let it ride.
And even with,
even with,
um,
what I'm doing as far as comedy,
man,
it's like dog.
It's really cool to make people laugh.
Like I've,
I've gotten to that point.
I've been angry dude.
But now it's really cool to make people laugh,
man.
It's really fucking
cool.
Well,
you're pushing positive instead of negative,
you know,
that's what it is when you have to find some shitty things in your life to
figure out what you don't want to be doing.
Learn from your mistakes and then you move on.
Yeah.
And just like,
just like,
uh,
for instance,
and something else with being in solitary confinement is,
I'm not as concerned with what goes on around me as far as which,
which was that first statement that I was making as far as racism.
But we had to clear that up.
I don't care.
I am a country music fan.
I like country music.
I love probably because I'm a drinker first,
but I like,
I like coaching me.
I don't even know why I like it.
I like Dwight Yoakam.
I like a lot.
Mostly all of it man.
Like other than that country pop shit where you,
where you got pop stars.
They couldn't make it as pop.
So they tried to do country.
Now I think that's a little bit much.
But other than that,
like straight country.
I love it
man.
Well I'm a big Johnny Cash fan,
but I never even think of Johnny Cash is being country.
Johnny Cash is like some weird white rap.
I said that Johnny Cash Fan.
I wouldn't say I'm a country music fan
boy named sue.
That song,
man,
that's sad.
It's not really a country music song man.
Get Away with that back though.
Cut off a piece of my ear and he said he has a fucking,
it was a song about a knife fight with his dad was his dad cuts off a piece of
his ear.
It was written by one,
his name Shel Silverstein.
That poet.
Really,
man,
he didn't write that.
It's like his song.
He made it his Silverstein.
I have to respect Shel Silverstein.
I'm still stolen,
but I've noticed that you say the word dog alive.
Is that something you've been doing your whole life for it?
Cause I mean Brian is block.
I know,
but I,
I've never,
I don't have a word like that.
I guess you need to get one son.
That's my word.
I need to get a word.
You'll cat cat.
I can say cat.
Hey Kat.
No,
I guess it's a DC thing too.
We like that Stephens is the d set that and like that like player player play
is.
That might've been one of the funniest things that's ever been said on the
podcast.
Not For tickle employer.
That might've been,
it might've been one of the top lines.
Sure.
Out of that.
Cause I would get lost and
there's a,
if there's a demand we might have to start doing podcasts,
quote,
tee shirts.
And that's a pretty good one.
Particularly for the one with you that on the Wikipedia too though.
I'm on my man.
Oh there's already 10 entries in the Wikipedia were put people put that in.
Of course I'm on some man.
Shit,
what dog?
That's how I like see you as,
because you know the only way comics is basically like dealing with females for
the strippers,
strippers,
so like,
so like talking to Joe is cool because that's what I call it.
Like Joe is on some mass yet so we can just talk as two men without me having to
worry about hurting his feelings or saying something that now you in a corner of
fucking crying or some shit like that.
So it's like,
that's why I say it's a man.
Shit.
It's like dog.
It's just two men fucking compensating.
You know what I'm saying?
Proceeding.
I love that word.
And you hear that crackling in the background.
What the fuck is that?
That is the volcano.
The sound was the,
that's the compressor.
The crackling.
The crackling is the plastic bag that contains the pure THC myth.
People actually wrote that on his witness down.
He's,
that's the exhale people wrote down your wake up that people wrote it like 10
times.
Man.
How'd he wrote on his?
I want some man.
Shit.
I'm all right.
Good.
Don't be scared.
I guess that means I had it.
Come on man.
This is the home stretch.
Okay.
Fuck it.
You know what I'm talking about?
That's what I'm talking about,
dude.
Just push it in and take a deep breath.
Take a deep breath.
Deep breath and then blow it out.
That's what I'm talking about,
dog.
You'd probably be good with one.
Keep you at one.
We don't want him to get to going crazy here and trying to call it.
That is what?
A podcast right there.
All right.
Do you want anybody?
Ooh,
trying to claw the,
the walls up so you know Tony Woods.
Cause you were a DC guy.
No,
he was.
Tony did.
Tony is a funny guy.
He is incredible.
Tom Woods out there.
Holler at me if you're ever in La.
I love to have you on the podcast.
Tony is one of the funniest comics that I've ever liked.
How was that?
I was in New York one night and Tony was doing the old Boston right.
It was four people in,
in the audience,
right.
Tony is crushing.
Some lady has to go to the bathroom.
She's like,
could you wait as he waits for it to come back because 20 more minutes.
He's the only guy I've ever seen.
You get a standing o from four people.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
There's something about doing those fucking sets.
We should talk about that at the comedy store too,
that does those sets that you would get where there's only like 10 people in the
audience or less.
It's so much fun.
I did two with danger fields,
wants me and a bunch of other dudes.
It was like three,
three other comics that also did sets in front of fucking two people.
It was one of those gigs where danger fields is a weird place.
You know,
it was like,
it was Rodney Dangerfield,
but was it still down the street from,
from the comic strip I was nowadays
remember,
I don't even remember what street it was on.
I know it was somewhere on the east side.
I did a lot of gigs in there though.
Yeah,
it was Isa.
But,
um,
when I lived in New York that was like one of my main spots cause they give you
what they called Prom shows and what prompts shows were,
and I did these with our blue bell and I did these with a auto and George and a
couple other guys.
I can't remember their names,
but what we did was we,
we were forced to do that.
They never took the audience out.
They would stuff them in with kids.
They were all like 17 and drunk and throwing up and fallen out of their chairs
and then violent like one big football player got on stage and and blues,
fucking cigar smoke and Al Belle's face and took the microphone from him and no
one did shit about it.
Man.
It was a big ass kid.
He was a big kid and you know they would do as these kids would be,
they would do their prom,
they would have their prom and then they would come to a comedy show and they
never took the audience out.
They just kept pumping more people in.
So they wanted you to come up again.
Do you would do five or six shows in a night.
So they would have a rotation,
they would have a host and then they'll have like an opener and then the second
guy,
the third guy,
and then you would go back up again and the same people would be there.
It would be there and they would say you have to do the same act cause we want
to get rid of them.
But you're not going to do the same act.
You're not going to want to eat it,
man.
You're not going to want to bomb.
So they would tell you to do the same Mac and I always a,
I be like,
look man,
you hired me to do comedy.
You can't tell me what comedy to do.
Right.
You know,
once you,
you're going to throw me out five times a night,
that's all good.
But you're not,
you can't tell me what comedy do.
I'm not going to die up there still kids who are still there.
And you would do a half hour sets and you would word it depends.
Sometimes we have 20 minutes.
Depends on how many people are in the show.
But the kids were there and you would do your,
your sat and they wanted you to go and do the exact same set for the exact same
kids in an hour and a half.
That is,
they wanted to get rid of the kids and you know,
they would just put,
people would just pull up in limos and then the guy would come in every now and
then if you're going the show,
this guy is Bobby,
have you seen the show?
Have you seen a show?
If you've seen it,
please leave.
And these kids are just running around like fucking animals.
So I did that play.
So danger fields was a weird club man.
It was real weird.
It was real dark and nobody went there.
Man.
It was fucking a small crowds all the time and not the best comics.
I've,
to be honest,
it wasn't like the highest level guys.
The highest level guys were at the Strip and in catch a rising star back then.
So anyway,
this fucking couple comes in.
We're all sitting around.
In my spot was at like eight o'clock and I got there and everybody was just
sitting in the,
um,
in,
in the bar area and the show was already supposed to start it.
I'm like,
what the fuck's going on?
And they were like,
there's no one here.
I go,
No one zero.
And then right when we were saying that two people showed up right this way,
ladies and gentlemen,
right this way.
And they lead them into the showroom.
Like these people have no idea.
We're here to see the shell and they pay their money and they get their tickets.
They think there's a fucking show gone.
They walk in there,
it's dead empty.
And they sit down by themselves and ladies,
gentlemen,
please welcome your emcee for this evening.
And he brings up the MC and the MC was some dude,
he had like,
oh look,
a little keyboard on stage to do this kind of a musical thing.
So he goes up in front of two fucking people and then another comic goes up and
he does his set.
And then I went up and I did my sat and then I had another guy went up and we
did,
we did a real full show for two people.
Sweet.
Cool.
It was.
But when you do those man,
it's like you get a weird connection with people that you don't get.
You know,
you don't,
you don't get in a big ass.
I have done something very similar a couple of times,
but I don't do my regular shit.
Then I ended up just fucking around and being real like sarcastic like yeah.
So I went to the store,
you know like,
like I wouldn't,
I do it a completely different just because I,
I don't even want to bother trying.
Well
my whole thing,
I went to the store,
you actually could do the opposite and it would help your act and the opposite
being you,
you know,
realize like how much of your axioms fake and you can get away with it because
there's 200 people as opposed to when you're telling it just to one person,
you can really trim the fat off your material that way.
You know,
for me,
I find small crowds really make you trim the fat because you,
you,
you're not putting on a show anymore.
You're talking to people and so,
yeah,
and when you're doing that,
you know,
you really get to the real meat of the topic better instead of like some
bullshit show stuff where you're saying things.
So first I not really,
well,
I thought
plus the plus the fact that me personally,
I think that if you paid your money,
it doesn't matter if it's two or like a hundred dog y'all,
y'all pay just as much as the rest of these people.
So why not give y'all something other than me fucking around like I,
that's one thing I personally hate coming from New York is when people are like,
oh,
it's a full house tonight.
Who gives a fuck?
It's,
it's five people here and all of them are paying $8 a fucking drink less.
I have some fun.
You know what I'm saying?
That's how I look at it.
It was worse than the of slaves.
There is no disappointment,
especially with me at the stage that I'm at.
I know that y'all didn't come to see me anyway.
So for me to be arrogant,
that's even more of me being a jackass.
Yeah.
It's just shit.
You feel like more pressure.
That's what it feels like.
Doesn't feel more pressure for you.
And there's like only a couple of people.
No,
I,
I don't even try.
So why not?
Why don't you try it?
Because it's just,
to me,
that's just,
I don't know.
I just,
when I'm clearly your father,
mother fucker needs coffee more than I've done it three times and all three
times.
I just just,
it was like,
fuck,
there's two people there.
I don't give a shit,
but why wouldn't he give a shit?
Why wouldn't you treat those two people?
Like it's a real show.
Oh,
for now it's the energy to,
to waste on TV.
Oh God.
Okay.
Right.
If there's two people there,
like didn't those,
what makes,
I dunno.
Like I,
they still special.
Here's the thing with me,
I started Cami,
completely different.
I,
you know,
I think of it as like I could jump on Ustream and talk to two people,
but I jumped on Ustream and I talked in like a hundred people immediately.
You know,
it's,
to me that's,
that's way worth it.
Then going to a comedy club and doing the same thing in front of two people that
they're like,
who's this guy on stage?
You know,
like that person is never going to follow me.
That person is not.
If I do good,
those two people are just going to most likely just going to go away and not
even remember that night.
That's a weird way of looking at it
like Noah,
but you're absolutely right.
Basically.
Hold on.
Gosh,
we can't talk over each other like that.
You're absolutely right though man.
Because when you say that you started comedy differently,
that's true because like I've had to do those shows,
right?
Like I've had to do a show for two people period and you haven't had to do that
I guess.
I don't know.
I mean I do,
I do.
I do open mic almost every day and I do it in front of two people.
I've done it.
We've,
what's even worse is five people that have seen your act a million times cause
they're all comics and they're not even a real audience.
But you're like,
why am I doing so like doesn't he worked with Uli joke?
Yeah.
So then if you're doing that,
you already know that it's practice for you to perform a lot of pizzas too easy
for you to get on stage.
You don't appreciate it enough.
If you were really grinding,
if you were really trying to really be a comic,
you're talking about the situations I'm in,
which is open mikes.
Yeah,
it's,
it's like most of the time if there's two people,
two people in that audience,
man,
you got to treat those two people.
Like that's a crowd.
It's harder to do,
but you're not doing a real show and open mics.
You're just fucking around.
So like when I go on stage,
I'm not going to a full,
but you're doing material right?
I do.
I'd love to just sit there with a thumb up my ass.
I'm just saying I don't do my normal shit.
I fucking just sit there and be like,
so you know,
I do it like a completely different act.
It's like,
Hey,
I'm not you like saying is that you don't have to do that.
You can do a version of your act that's,
that's better.
You know,
you could trim it down and trim it down for two people.
It's so,
sometimes it feels weird,
you know,
and,
and you realize what jokes that stand out in your act as being artificial when
you're,
when you're talking to two people,
man,
you can really,
you feel like the jokes that aren't good,
you know,
they're like,
man,
this one needs work.
This is the shits clunky.
It feels weird to talk to people.
But what I'm saying,
you can benefit if you really want to truly keep doing standup,
you can benefit from that just by doing your real set.
If you get a laugh from two people,
you know that joke is going on.
I guess the biggest reason why I think this is why I think it elevate.
Uh,
there's been so many times doing open mic where you do a new bit that you're,
you,
you believe in and you like it and it fucking no,
no one,
no response at all.
So you try it again,
same exact thing,
no response at all.
Then you get a real show and then you try that same bit and it fucking kills and
you're like,
God damn,
I almost lost that bit because that bit failed because you're in this horrible
atmosphere of like two people or
it's all a part of the vibe.
You got to,
you got to tune it all in.
It's all a part of the process of being a standup comic.
You know,
you can't really develop only in front of large audiences.
Once you've got your shit together,
then you could pretty much do any kind of audience.
I think you're thinking,
I'm saying something completely different cause you're,
you're making it seem like you don't like to perform when there's two people you
liked.
[inaudible] that's not my saying what section?
Saying that when I'm done,
there's two people in the audience,
I'm not going to fucking do a whole like,
hey,
so I went down the street.
I don't want to just kind of fuck around.
I'm not going to do my regular material.
I'm going to just go,
I'm not going to give them the,
I understand what you're saying.
So let's,
let's break that down.
Let's just of interesting,
no,
he's got say pretty basic.
It's kind of interesting.
Let's break that down because what you,
what you're saying is that you're not going to give them this like,
hey,
like really animated when he's saying,
I'm not saying that.
I like how I considered like that the act that I do is takes a lot of like
timing and,
and like,
uh,
like it's a whole process.
It's not just sitting out there going,
blah,
blah.
It's kind of like,
it's more work than then just saying,
you know what,
I'm just going to fuck around and do some,
some bits,
you know,
just try some stuff or,
or,
you know,
just fuck around.
So I would,
so if there's two people in the audience,
I'm not going to like bother trying to like change my whole act to go around to
people,
you know what I'm saying is why does it have to be changed?
Because it's funnier if you say certain things when there's an audience.
It's,
it's funny if you say the same thing in front of two people is you should say it
different.
You agree if there's a group of people,
right?
Sometimes it depends on what you're talking about,
what I could sign it.
They're completely different in,
in front of 400 people then two people.
Right?
But why even fuck around trying to even do the math of how it would work best?
Wouldn't you just want to be like,
hey,
there's two pp or I'm just gonna fuck around some new shit.
I think,
um,
I think you have to address the fact,
obviously this is only two people.
You have to make some light to that.
But then once you do that,
you can pretty much,
if your act as tight,
you could pretty much do your act.
But you know,
could or you could just fuck around.
You know,
why even try to change things.
Because what I'm saying is for me
when I do small crowds,
it makes me well aware of the Ed,
the space that I have on my act and I need to trim out like I'm talking too much
here or this is too disingenuous or this is so this seems a little fake.
You can tell it's like,
yeah,
this is like my segway.
The segway is like ham handed,
you know this,
this punchline is like a little like sticky,
like yeah.
Yeah.
I feel the difference when I do
cause I mean like me personally,
I wish that I knew when I did the shows for four people that I would be playing
for 200 sometime in the near future.
So that's why I was more like whenever I get onstage,
no matter how many people it is,
I got to make the most of this being on a stage.
Even in,
even in New York where I was,
where you get onstage a lot more.
Even there,
it's like,
oh,
I used to always just be like,
I'm so grateful to be onstage at all.
First of all.
Second of all,
um,
maybe I just appreciate that these people would even listen to my bullshit.
Who in the fuck am I that I'm looking at y'all like it should be more.
Yeah,
I want to
do it.
You have to think about it like that.
You know,
you have to be almost obsessed with it.
You know?
Oh,
I'm saying about this,
uh,
doing,
you know,
doing shows and not appreciating it as much or not thinking about as much.
Brian has.
One point that's really important is that when you're starting out and you start
eating,
anytime you eat it,
it chips away a big chunk of your confidence.
And when you can look at something and go,
well,
this is just not even set up for comedy.
Why am I fucking running uphill with sandbags?
You know,
this is getting,
give me a bad feeling.
I'm going to go up there and do some jokes that I have some,
you know,
some hope for and they're gonna die because it's not an easy crowd.
So that point too,
I see
that point too,
but uh,
yeah,
there's both.
It's really,
it's not either or there's bolts.
It's a completely personal preference.
And like last time I was on stage was right after we got out of Portland,
I decided to do an open mic at Sal's and I decided,
you know what,
just as an idea,
because I had just done five shows in a row as certain way,
I'm going to do the exact same way at south there was about eight people in the
audience.
I did the exact,
like almost a recorded version of what I just did the whole week just to see
what happens.
And it was the most awkward mother fucking thing ever.
I'll let you listen to the,
it's so weird.
I started like I have a part of my act where I just started doing this where I
have a really uncomfortable pause,
you know?
And then mostly like there would be like a couple of people that start get it
like,
okay,
I get it now.
This is creepy at league and then a bunch of people start laughing.
I did that.
They're in front of eight people,
no one.
There was never that one person that just started giggling to get it to to make
the other people laugh and so that it was just like complete silence.
It was so weird.
You blame the audience or do you blame the way you perform?
No,
no.
I think the whole idea of that bit,
that one particular bit is that there's going to be a few people that get it and
start giggling and then the other pages really can't,
can't really come into to the mob mentality and everyone will laugh at one
person.
It's,
it's where I said,
you're a fucking porn star.
Right,
and just sit there and sit there and it's something,
a couple of people giggle and then suddenly everyone starts fucking giggling.
It's like this new thing I started importantly,
so I did that at South Korea's not that one.
We'll get to it.
Sometimes people are giggling just because they want to laugh.
Sometimes people are Google them because they're at a comedy show and no one
drinks and they just want to laugh.
And if you give them a pause and they're laughing at some stuff before,
they'll just start laughing.
Right,
right.
But it's,
that's not what in this case,
this case,
this case is the whole bit is I can't give away my bit,
but you know that what you're saying is that people put it together was like
comparing that with,
wait,
you're a fucking porn star.
So one person starts giggling.
Not Making enough sense without saying the bill.
So anyways,
well I know what you're saying.
No,
but I know what he's saying.
It's like it's something like if you have,
you gotta got to adjust when there's a small crowd.
It's that simple.
I know what you're saying.
I just,
so you just wanted to try it as an experiment to not adjust,
not adjust.
Did you do,
exactly.
I worked on some bits.
Somebody who's completely worked fine.
Did you feel like bailing out halfway into it though?
Because it's eight people and most of these people were just other comics.
So I was just like,
you know,
I'm gonna experiment with this.
That's one good thing about what we're doing every day is just experimenting.
You know?
That's just an experiment.
So what happens?
It's like a video again.
Like am I try jumping over this platform once we recommend whatever you do,
don't try to bomb.
Oh I don't try to bomb.
And it's not like,
and it's not like this is one thing you would tell someone and I tried,
I'm just thinking about going up there and bombing on purpose.
That's the beauty of open mic though.
That's one of those things where as though,
cause you lived in New York for awhile,
right Joe?
Yeah.
That's one of the things that being out here and being in New York,
I think when you are in New York doing comedy stage time is like yes you get on
stage more.
But it's kind of harder to,
cause when I was there I had to pay to go up on open mics.
I had to either pay $5 or buy a couple of drinks or do something to get our open
mics.
That was like six years ago.
I don't know if it's changed since then,
but you had to spend money to get on that stage,
so no matter what or who was there,
you just spent some money to talk and now you're going to fuck around.
So I think at my level,
we didn't have time to play because I just paid to get on a stage,
so I'm going to try to get better.
Oh.
When I was there,
you had to either buy two drinks,
which for comics was like $6 we all,
she had to pay $5 and dark for mostly every open mic.
At a comedy club?
Yeah.
$5.
Wow.
Cafe or Moda?
Most places.
Most places make you buy her a drink.
Sounds does.
It makes you buy a drink.
I think it was a comics up to buy a now to spend $5 and you get a ticket and
then you're allowed to go on stage.
But actually,
so it's common.
Common.
It's common.
It's not.
I'm in,
but it's in La,
it's common.
It's looked at.
The most important thing is that there is some sort of an open mic system.
Right.
It's unfortunate when you get an open mic system,
it makes you pay it.
I don't mind it because I'm going to fucking buy a beer,
but still some guys don't have five bucks every day.
Like I told,
I told Boone,
you guys know Boone,
he,
he's a homeless guy.
I think he's home on this,
but he isn't open or he's a miker and he,
I think he's hilarious.
And he was like,
I'm like,
why aren't you going to,
you know,
sounds anymore.
And he goes,
well,
because I,
I can't afford that,
you know,
five bucks.
And I'm like,
look,
I have one or two beers.
I have two or three beers at least every time I go to south,
you just let me know.
I'll buy you a beer,
get you a ticket,
you know,
so,
um,
you can mooch off my beers
plugin.
It's crazy.
It's a fun,
crazy because in New York,
like I remember talking to sell whether he was going to start a charge,
he's like,
yeah,
might as well cause it's like nobody that's not really common from what I've
seen here when I first got here.
But now it's coming.
Young people going to have to kick out and I think a lot less of that plan will
be going on as far as,
well I can just play around because dog,
you just kicked out and
if you're going to do it and if you're going to have a place to call up,
five bucks is not bad.
And if you know,
if that's the difference between having an open mic night and not having an open
mic night,
then it's worth the five bucks because it's the most important thing,
man.
Stage time,
getting,
getting good spots,
getting a bunch of people around you.
There's no substitute for it in the beginning,
right?
No,
not at all.
You know,
you gotta just hustle.
You got to do it all.
Even the stuff that sucks,
it just jump up there.
It's dude,
people
cry.
As we were talking about,
I mean like,
you know,
you gotta be up there,
you've got gotta be practicing no matter what.
I mean,
like I know shit.
I'm pretty much it,
you know,
we're the same level almost.
I mean like just,
I'm right above the open mic phase at my fucking point.
But uh,
when two people show up,
that means it was either them or nobody and they're doing you a favor just by
being there.
So,
I mean,
the least you can
do is give them your fucking all and adjust yourself to the room and all that
the most,
get it out,
you know,
appreciative you are in every situation.
The better the most that you appreciate every opportunity,
the better.
And that's,
you know,
there's negative at to it,
but it's also the,
you can do,
you could turn down around,
one person can go up in front of that same crowd and kill,
you know,
I'm an,
I've seen that before where I didn't like something I didn't leave the room was
not to my liking or whatever and I went up with a shitty attitude I'm going to
do to go on after you and kill and you're like,
okay,
I was an idiot,
you know.
Now I know.
You know I was young and stupid and it,
now I've made a mistake and now I learned from that shit
cause it's like,
I guess to be honest,
I'm just appreciative of the fact that
his legal,
first of all,
this is legal and second of all people let me talk some shit to him,
man.
Like if you were telling me when I was in jail that I'd ever be doing this or
like anything of this nature,
I told you he was crazy.
How much are you getting worked out?
You getting roadwork and Shit,
you have an STD that just came out too,
right?
Oh,
it's coming out.
They actually pushed the date back.
Hold on.
It's coming.
It's coming out on August the first now iTunes.
Uh,
yeah,
but it's actually,
um,
it's actually the first a CD that's coming out on George Carlin's label other
than his,
other than his word,
your manager situation.
Skype keeps giving you shit advice.
Motherfucker got lucky with George Carlin
dog.
It didn't take much work,
Jared,
and just really whatever you are a fellow.
No,
Jerry.
Jerry has a good,
it's the only,
it's the only CD other than Georgia has worked to ever come out on what's it
called?
It's called wildly inappropriate wild.
And yes,
your mom's going to get autographed copies,
but it's like,
um,
it's like that.
And I,
I'd like to thank Kelly man.
Kelly is Kelly Kelly Collins.
Awesome.
She's awesome.
Kelly George's daughter,
our daughter Kelly Carlin,
she,
uh,
she was the producer for a,
Paul showed yes,
she'd hundred producers for that.
Right.
She's awesome because she heard my CD and she's like,
Oh hey,
cool.
Like,
cause you have to clear it with all of these people because it's their father.
So are you,
um,
are you doing standup on the road now?
I still don't have a TV credit coat into a coin to a lot of comedy club owners.
I don't have a TV credits.
You can't even get like middle work.
Nobody's going to let me middle form.
What Doug?
Nobody's not let me middle for.
Well who says that?
Why?
Why do you say that?
It's happened too many times I've gotten complaints from middles.
And what's the complaint first is to first it's that I'm too dirty and then,
and then the second show I'll do my whole act clean and then the third show I'll
take out certain jokes that they don't want it done.
And by the fourth show is normally just fuck them.
It's just like we can't stop this dude from doing what he does.
And um,
so you meet your,
so you're saying they don't want you and because you're too good,
is that what you're saying?
That's I would think,
but
that's kind of arrogant.
So I'm just like been there for some of these fucking shows where he's gotten,
because he's scared to fall.
You call them out.
Who are they?
No,
it's been one of them had time for this.
Oh yeah,
that one was good when it was funny.
The position to call Omar for.
Okay,
well why don't you tell me the name and I'll call them out.
I'm not doing that either.
You Agley hit them with some subtle chest shit moves ahead.
I didn't go three gotta go.
Three army got to go through but it isn't dues.
Like I have some fucked up stories man.
And it's like so guys take you on the road with them.
No,
no,
no.
I'm just talking about just from Hollywood.
People have seen my act in there like there's no way in hell I'm taking them on
the road
and it's just cause you're too dirty.
What does it curve?
Maybe know what I'll just say cause I'm too dirty even though I don't consider
myself dirty,
dirty,
astute on the road world with me.
Joey does being dirty and Joey that's ever existed to see his balls in the green
room.
I want us,
I don't want to say it's because I'm too funny cause who knows.
Funny is funny as well.
If you're following shit comics,
there are comics that want only scrubs to go on before them.
It's a real common thing.
Like there's a lot of people that get surprised when they come to see some of my
shows.
I'm like dude,
you got or we should fear and Joey Diaz going on in front of you.
Like those guys are both headlines,
which is,
which is because I think it's cause you're like you're like a a comic.
I mean you're a comedian.
You aren't somebody.
This just here to just say a couple of jokes and get on a sitcom.
Like you really take this as an art and as part of the art of comedy,
you don't want scrubs up
front of me.
I don't want anybody to suffer,
suffer through any bad.
Exactly.
I don't understand why you would even think like that because to me I think it's
like riding waves one like wouldn't you want to bury?
You have the guy who goes on in front of you and barely gets by for 20 minutes
or whatever and the crowd gets uncomfortable and then the comic,
the main event guy comes out and just comes out guns blazing and crushes.
It makes you look like a fucking superhero.
Yeah,
the other guy bombed and you just destroyed in.
There's some guys like that and they need it and the last thing they want to do
is be in the green room ready to go on and hear some guy out there killing like
it fucks with them.
They're taking away from my crowd.
There was a comic wouldn't even allow his black comic,
he wouldn't let our buddy who's a black dude open forum because it was in his
claws with his manager that no other black comic will go on before me because I
want to black it up.
Well there was a really funny he got but you still always talk about that on the
east coast.
It was funny how if you were to go on the road and there's two white guys and
one black guy,
the black guy is always like,
yo Yo I was supposed to headline,
I was supposed to headline but if there's the black guy shows up and there's two
other black guys like yo I got to go on first,
I got to go on first because they're doing the same material.
I don't care cause like I haven't heard no black guy say some of the shit that I
say so I don't care like and even even with some of the comics like you were
talking about roadwork,
like I'm in Vegas,
the law,
the next gig that I got booked is for Vegas.
I like the first week of June I get no work because I'm in that nexus of he's
not funny enough to headline by us.
I'm going to ask what's your for nobody you sell,
you set yourself up.
You got like some negative little roadblocks in your head as because down them
and you like,
people ain't going to let me and this is going to happen and I got a,
because people want to fuck with me because you have this,
you have this little thing in your head.
You automatically are in conflict with people you like.
People don't want to,
the people don't want to middle me people don't they?
You just got to do your shit man.
Don't worry about that.
The people that are going to,
the people that are going to be intimidated by you don't dwell on them.
Don't even,
well I'm not and that's why I think that things are getting better for me as far
as career wise and mentally wise like it.
Don't even bring that stuff up in conversation.
Just abandoned those thoughts that I was talking about just because you asked
that question,
but what he's holding you back,
man,
that's,
I'm telling you,
nobody's trying to hold you back.
I know that because the whole thing is I don't care if they work,
it's,
it's my job to be the best that I can be on that stage.
That's all anybody that's all that I can control.
Like I can't control who wants to take me on the road.
I can't control who wants to make,
how many times you've been on the road by myself or do you go on the road a lot?
No,
I just worked like books me at his Improv's where's Bud's Improv?
Oh,
his,
his Vegas and Tahoe.
He still needs still books.
Vegas.
He still was,
he just retired but saw me one night.
And I guess you're talking about,
um,
but Friedman,
Bud Freeman,
the legendary guy from the Improv with the Monaco.
Remember those emails the put on?
Yeah.
So I play Improv's and I'm like buds and thrives and then I,
um,
play Vegas Song,
but that's about it,
man.
That's too far.
As far as me and traveling,
that's about it.
I really haven't gotten on the road with any,
like,
I've never worked with anybody on the road on the road.
Oh,
now that you've got the showtime special,
you'd be able to get some gigs,
right.
Hopefully yet.
Oh,
George Carlin's manager in the showtime special Bro.
Yeah,
hopefully.
Yeah.
Put it all together.
Hopefully.
So if people want to get ahold of you,
they get you on Twitter.
Yes,
Darrell underscore.
Right.
And Brian is Brian Whittaker and of course red band.
Very weird.
Ben's very upset of his Twitter follower.
Yeah.
I don't have it so low,
so low.
I don't get so many people hate me.
I had a dog collar I today,
Joe,
I don't know it was going to itself for the girlfriend,
but it has like 10 levels and like the first level,
you know,
it's very mild.
And then if it keeps on barking,
it gets higher and higher and goes after these 10 levels.
Right,
right.
So we had Ma'am Miller on today's I skeptic tank with Articia fear and we
decided to like,
Hey,
my Pekinese is wearing this.
It's not going to be that bad.
So may and puts it around his neck barks and fucking,
he's just like,
this is awful.
This is awful.
And I'm like,
all right,
are you have to tripe?
Didn't think that that it went up another level because of that.
Cause he barked every time we do the kitchen and it had already,
because my dog had made it go up to like level two or three or something like
that.
So it was already on like level three.
Then Ari puts it on right on his throat,
like on his neck.
Embark's shocks the fuck out.
I'm like,
all right,
it's not that bad.
And,
but I wasn't going to do it.
I was like,
fuck that you guys,
you know.
So I was holding,
I want to hold it and they were laughing so hard and I started laughing that it
vibrated and it made the noise and shock me,
enhance my hands.
Still fuels numb.
It's pretty shocked.
It doesn't fucking,
what the Hell's his name?
Um,
Jason.
Alice doesn't need to like fights were dance.
We're dog collars and it shocked them remotely.
That's what,
how,
why we decided to do it because the man was talking about,
he just did it with nick Swardson where they had fights and then they had him
like wrap it around the all eggs and stuff and which is
via that.
Oh,
just drop dude.
I am not down with that.
Yeah,
those guys are crazy.
I got played today.
Jason Ellis show.
Yes or nos.
Yeah.
He's electrocuting themselves.
That's ridiculous.
Why get Ellis on here man?
I will do.
He was,
I'm supposed to do his show too where we have it in planning.
Electrocuting it because it's hot man.
Right.
So next week will be on Monday and Tuesday next week.
Um,
and uh,
times and guests and all that shit to follow this weekend.
Joey and Ari and I are at field helium in Philadelphia.
I almost said filium Philadelphia.
That's what happens at the end of the show folks.
Your brain is done.
Um,
so,
uh,
if you're in Philly,
come on down.
It's all sold out,
I think.
Uh,
there was only a couple of tickets left for Thursday night late show.
That was all that was left.
We added a late show Thursday.
That's how we roll.
We're like Gabriel Iglesias but white
Gabriel.
We'll do five shows on a Monday.
That motherfucker rakes it.
Um,
so,
uh,
if people want to get ahold of you,
best way,
Twitter,
Facebook,
whatever,
Facebook and Brian,
please follow.
Brian gets so sad.
Just sad.
What are you up to now?
Huh?
What do you have to know?
I think I worked about 18,000 or 10,000 away from Michael on them before you
came in jail.
I got,
I got to fucking,
I got to stock her before I got any fans.
I got somebody who made a fake page on me on Facebook and I checked it yesterday
and uh,
I was thinking,
oh,
maybe I got some other fans I didn't hear about.
It was one follower on this fake page.
Wow.
Just so depressing.
It was like,
Damn.
Somebody made a fake page out of me and I got one fake fan checkout desk.
Got that TV though for the,
the death squad podcasts and subscribe to that.
Please
do whatever the fuck you want to do.
Folks.
Don't listen to anybody including him.
Please see you guys in Philly.
See you next week.
Monday and Tuesday for the podcast.
And that's it.
Yes.
So what do we want for all of the plaque?
Has guys that hung,
hung around with the,
all of this craziness.
Thank y'all for watching guys.
This was fun.
Thank you Joe for having me.
Thanks for being powerful.
See Your bitches.
Fleshlight fleshlight our sponsor is a,
if you go to Joe rogan.net and click on the link that the little flashlight link
and enter in the code name Rogan,
you get 15% off so you get a discount on your masturbation.
It's a quality product made by nice people,
white and blue.
Only unfortunately,
clear white,
blue and clear.
Only though unfortunately no black and white.
There's no black vaginas.
Yeah,
thanks so white and clear.
Brilliant.
Now you know Joe going to plug a tour.
I got sure plugging a smiling dot comedy,
um,
would go going with Rick Shapiro.
I'm up north the bay area for a few days coming up this Saturday and started the
purple onion and then off,
I think somewhere else in San Francisco.
I don't know,
but that you can follow that shit on Twitter to just smiling.
Dot comedy comedy.
That's what it is on Twitter will be powerful show.
They just love you.
See?
Yeah.
Bye Bye.